let me ask my brother can should come is
the
audio a [__] touchdown there's a flag
though thank
God I'm gonna ask my brother if the
audio is too
loud ah touchdowns coming back you
[__] is the game audio too
loud this Roku remote ain't working Roku
I'm going to be honest not as great as I
thought you were oh that's what I'm
looking up my prize picks let's keep
track of how this goes as if my as if I
haven't lost enough in my
life oh
right okay I got CD lamb getting more
than 74 and a half yards don't ask me
why the [__] I thought that would happen
uh I got Austin Eckler getting more than
50.5 rush yards and I got Brandon Cooks
getting less than 36.5 rush yards that's
a $50 bet on uh that's a $50 pick on
price picks not a bet that's my bad
I mean what an absolute [__]
dude they just did the exact same
thing was that a rush cuz if so my prize
pick is looking Dandy or was that a
screen pass I just looked up and he was
running down the
sideline I'll tell you what if the
Cowboys get their doors blown again
today Mike McCarthy might get fired and
then at least hey you know what guys if
you're a Cowboy fan you know what misery
loves company so let's all be [__]
suellen together what my brother say
about the audio TV's loud hey K I'll
turn it up there's a there's a knob back
there on the left hand bottom side cuz
the Roku TV remote's not working look at
that stupid [__] Roku [__]
idiots that ain't it that's input there
it
is he said the chat just went
off
nothing is
up I'm just GNA call my brother on the
air and see what's going on right here
okay oh we up hey hey we got the chat
I'm going to hang up on my brother my
bad all right what's up man uh volume is
not too loud it's perfect hey thank you
my brother is [__]
the harsh critic for no
reason if they get blown out tonight who
am I calling for who oh my God are you
[__] kidding
me that's the quickest touchdown I've
ever seen in my
life let call my
brother hey bu the everybody saying the
volume is is fine and you're wrong and
uh you were right about one thing the
Cowboys are not
good
yeah they're not have you given up on
Dak
officially I mean yeah he's just he's
Tony rooll 2.0 this whole team sucks
like tyon Smith sucks the offensive line
is trash everything sucks so yeah I mean
it all seems pretty terrible right now I
don't think everyone sucks but the team
as a whole sucks the whole team doesn't
suck but the team as a whole sucks you
see what I'm saying the organization
sucks yes the organization sucks Jerry
Jones won't die it's really bothering me
I just need one me too allegation
that's all I need is that so crazy
shved those he canv yeah this guy he's
Immortal we need a mi3 for jry
Jones you might need a lot more than me3
you might need like a [__] nuclear
bomb we might bro all right i'mna live
forever I'm gonna address the chat
during the commercial break I'll call
you if I get frustrated about Dak again
my brother is a big deck Prescott
supporter forever hated Tony Romo
refused to believe they were the same
quarterback I try to tell him all the
time now he finally gets it same ass
quarterback just different ways of
failing one was more skilled one's a
better leader they both just failed
don't make me bring up when you gave up
on Dirk I did give up on Durk I gave up
hard on Dirk but that says I'm
racist at least I'm honest what's your
excuse I know dude your your stream is
way behind because I'm just now getting
uh you talking about me texting oh yeah
yeah yeah it be slow sometimes but I
I'll love you I I'll talk to you later
all right later bye love you
somebody asked if I was getting Blau on
the Pod I think you I think we will
raguram you'll see tomorrow Michael
blowstein on flagrant pod that's my
brother I'm so excited to have him
on Jerry Jones is better than having
Mark Davis I don't even know if that's
true man it's about the same at least
Mark Davis you got a fun haircut to look
at you know what I
mean Kev can we move that lamp a little
bit so I can see the oh yeah we got to
set up my phone I'm going to get get on
IG live yo we don't bet we do prize
picks out here dude it's it's like
fantasy but more fun and less you know
nerdy just one game that's all you got
to do cowboys should tank and get Caleb
Caleb Williams you understand they even
if they lost the next 12 games they'd be
three and 13 and that probably wouldn't
be the worst record in the league I just
want you to think about that three and
14 I guess actually or 17 games but
still you see what I'm saying that's
still not
enough
Jay Victory just asked how many edies
are we going for tonight do you need my
phone or you can use your phone for Life
hey thanks Kev appreciate
it dude I'm a huge football fan I'm from
Texas how would I not be a football fan
that'd be
crazy yeah guys blow this up Matt Chen
you're right dude everybody tell
somebody about it blow it
up and if you want to throw me money
that's cool too you know what I mean
maybe I could pay for some some wall art
cuz right now it's
barren
I am watching the World Cup India whack
that at I'm going to live stream the
World Cup probably uh definitely want to
live stream the England match on
Saturday that'll be fun [__] stupid
Brits I'll see you in December uh and
then I might live stream uh the match on
Thursday as well I think it's Thursday
right who are they playing
Afghanistan am I live on
IG oh can we flip that [__] so I can see
what they're
saying what's good
this is the worst
dude shout thoughts on Dion and and see
you blowing the lead to Stanford I think
Dion is gonna be fine yo you got to give
him two years two years two
years I mean this is just unbelievable
unbelievable
[__] that was the easiest
touchdown I'll tell you AJ why Brandon
Cooks hasn't been producing because Mike
McCarthy sucks hey what's up IG I'm
streaming the Cowboys Chargers ass
beating on YouTube I'm it's going to be
up here too but if you want to watch
with graphics and whatnot and where I'm
going to be looking a little bit more
check out YouTube youtube.com Akash
comedy I believe but hey what's up dude
mad comments already yo y'all are kind
of killing YouTube in terms of
Engagement I'm going to be honest with
you okay there you go CD lamb first down
I picked CD lamb and prize picks to get
more than what was it 79.5 receiving
yards I just felt like cuz he didn't get
targeted at all last week he's going to
get Targets this week so that's 12 yards
I'm almost there I'm almost there dude
just every Dak yard needs to go to him
look at that CD lamb again at least one
prize pick is looking all right Austin
Eckler I got faith in Brandon Cook's not
going to get the ball I got faith in
that too I picked him getting less than
yards what team do I go for Lawrence I'm
born and raised in Dallas I have to root
for the cowboy Bo is against my [__]
will it's a
nightmare hey look I got two pieces of
media going up dude your boy is live out
here I'm I'm
everywhere hey thank you switching gains
I appreciate
that I'm about to break for a deuce like
this video let's get 1,000 live in the
chat I like that let's do that tell
people Michael
Gallup you know how a good prize pick is
Michael Gallup less that's what I should
have done Michael Gallup less whatever
they're saying Michael Gallop
less Michael Gallup 05 yards
less I could hear myself that was weird
yo do I think Cricket kunov but do I
think Cricket will take off in the US no
it's better than baseball but baseball
has a strangle here it's America's ptime
it'd be traitorous to start playing
Cricket for these you
know
all right here we
go I don't understand why I gotta be
Chris Burman just because I'm telling
Kev what to do you know what I mean Kev
is my guy he's in charge of all I can't
do anything without you know why I only
got to stream 30 minutes of the World
Cup of cricket cuz Kev wasn't here and I
was helpless without him that's why he
didn't understand how what a big deal it
was he's a michigander he don't
know okay third and
three here comes a field goal I
think D press got more than two
interceptions that's weirdly not a stat
uh prize pick you can make but it should
be oh look at that a first
down hand off look at
that hey what's up guys thanks for
joining mad people joining appreciate
that when am I going to do a SE Calgary
I don't know I don't even know where
Calgary is on a map
really Canada I know
that hey thanks hey he I was on wilding
out like four episodes one of them I
didn't say a goddamn word I just stood
there like a mute they edited out all my
jokes that it was embarrassing posting
about it watching the episode being like
well I'm not in this I'm in it but I'm
not in
it oh man you like the white Cowboys
helmets I'm not a
fan cowb got the best uniform them and
the Niners got the best uniforms just
keep it as
is okay second and five that's
manageable right you can do that hey
look at Brandon Cooks in motion not
going to get the ball look at that look
at that what did I tell you
hey Michael Gallop less didn't I tell
you Michael Gallop
less hay he got a Cowboys money line
that that was foolish
he I'm gonna be honest I didn't think
they I actually thought they would win
this game but this is I mean that was
seven quick
points they didn't even get the ball
first that's I mean they got the ball
first too that's what's
crazy who just texted me someone just
texted me send me your P
screenshot oh yeah I'm going to send you
the screenshot of my pcks
dude hey dude I don't know if I have a
here actually there might be in my last
images I don't think I have a screen
recorder me picking
them third and five okay now it's fourth
and one uh no no it's the the Cowboys
game that's for next week I'm on prize
picks next week already boy I'm all over
these prize picks fourth and one and
they're kicking a field goal
if they're kicking a field goal you
should fire Mike McCarthy right now okay
thank
God creamsicle Bucks jerseys I don't
know how I feel about them dude I'm not
these powder blue San Diego jerseys or
Los Angeles jerseys whatever city
they're pretending they're in fire those
creamsicle joints I don't know oh my
goodness here we go Dak Prescott
touchdown look at that slow as molasses
this man that was crazy he used to be a
runner 18 yards that's a slow I could I
think I could outrun DEA
Prescott I
think yo I'm American Born Indian trying
to bag American Born Pakistani you got
to help me akash you know what you got
to
do find someone who hates her parents
that's your move dude that's how you do
it what's up IG what y'all got to say it
just keeps telling me people joined
ignore that up
top I am coming to DC actually check my
schedule somebody asked me to come to DC
I'm coming in January mid January I
think the 18th through the 20th or
something like that DCM improv come
through my TV is delayed well buddy what
you want for me that's the internet
that's not
me hey I can't believe it's seven all
dude I was ready to walk out of the if
honestly if I wasn't streaming this I'd
have i' have turned off the game at 70
thank y'all for keeping me
honest Dak almost f
that makes sense to me I saw that on the
replay forgot about
it do I did you play any sports chess
don't count I played tennis my senior
year of high school but I wasn't that
good I was just a little fat kid with a
lot of heart that's who I am I'm a
little fat kid with a lot of
heart I want to get back into it
though
any other questions guys when do I go
back to Wisconsin who knows cheese head
Bucky who plans another trip to
Wisconsin can I ask you that question
that's something I'd like to know yo why
is the chat why do I got to keep doing
this how come it don't just scroll with
me Kev why don't the new comments just
pop
up are you all the way at the bottom I'm
all the way at the bottom but then new
comments pop up and I got to keep
scrolling like that that's stupid that's
[__]
why don't I just say things and then ask
if I could say them after that's
probably a smart thing to do right say
like offensive things and then be like
can I say that on a live stream where I
can't really edit it that a good idea oh
hey thanks man give it up for big Kev
dude this guy's the best even though he
was late setting up the stream but
that's all good that's you know not here
there look at
that YouTube TV
lagging Pard over Rush somebody's asking
about their prize picture right now Pard
more rush yards Eckler more rush yards
Parsons one sack I mean those all seem
like solid picks dude I don't know I
don't know for a fact I'm I'll tell you
this on my prize picks I am ofer i' be
losing every time so what you do you
figure out what I picked kev's going to
put on the screen in a bit and you do
the opposite cuz I keep losing so I'm
the Dallas Cowboys at prize picks I keep
getting them wrong so just do the
opposite of what I do and you should
make money that should be enough right
there these are your picks oh here we go
yeah I forgot about this CD lamb more
than 74 and a half receiving yards
Austin Eckler more than 50 and a half
rushing yards Brandon Cooks less than 36
and a half receiving yards all these
seem like good picks to me but I don't
know but if you want to do it yourself
go to prize.com use the promo code aash
they're going to match your initial
deposit up to $100 that means if you put
in $100 you get $100 for free also my CD
lamb right now looking good Austin
Eckler we'll see how they do on the next
drive he had a screen pass for a lot of
yards that don't count and Brandon Cooks
and caught nothing so I think I'm in
good shape so far I mean 36 and a half
receiving yards is one Brandon Cooks
reception but I don't think he's going
to get the ball cuz Mike McCarthy does
know how to call plays so there you go
there's
that halfway through the first quarter
guys we are 1/8 of the way through this
thing you know let's go plus halftime 12
minutes whoa offensive player um I'm I'm
happy if I help help you like that man
he said he was contemplating suicide he
saw my special with the a bit and it
resonated with him and I'm glad I could
help man if I helped I'm I'm really
happy to hear that man that's a
beautiful thing God bless keep fighting
keep going we're all trying to make it
you're absolutely right everybody's
trying to make
it you know I don't like is the number
of people being streamed in the top
right corner that's demoralizing when
you see it going down and then you see
it getting up and you get dope and being
hit and then it goes back down what we
doing that for
hey IG live if you know how to um sauce
up an IG live with graphics and stuff
please let me know and I probably will
miss those so if YouTube knows why don't
you guys tell me because I don't know
I'm not going to look at the IG live
with a small font like that but I would
like the IG live viewers to also get the
you know the Gamecast at the bottom or
whatever that'd be fun at some point
this is probably going to go purely on
YouTube but right now we're doing
BofA
you know you remember two weeks ago when
we thought the Cowboys defense was
really good what happened to that where
did that
[Music]
go here's the thing about Kell Moore
that's the S that's the Los Angeles
Chargers offensive
coordinator he seems like he's really
good and then somehow he always does
stupid [__] like a a hi tight end
handoff like it you know what I mean it
just it seems in theory like this guy's
great
and then he hands the ball off to a
tight end in the back field and you're
like well what the hell was that about
and now it's third and seven I still
think they'll you know Justin Herbert is
probably gonna yep that's a okay play
got shut down thank
God somebody flag fall start delay Game
12 men on the field no they wouldn't
stop for 12 men on the field cheese head
Bucky I'm not doing a New Year's Eve
show as far as I know I am going to the
UK in December so come through your your
your ass
oh my god dude I hate this team the call
was 12 players in a formation I never
even heard such a stupid rule but
obviously the Cowboys would be the ones
that break
it
11 are the cowboys really India's
favorite team I don't know a lot of
Indians who watch American football to
be honest but they are kind of the
world's team so he probably
[Music]
um a a just asked when the specialist
coming out we filmed it in September I
don't know we're editing it right now
I'm hoping for end of this year or early
next year but we'll we'll
see that was a drop dude that was a
drop fourth and two fourth and two
favorite food to eat while watching
football
nachos Alberto just asked me that nachos
what's the other answer Pizza is kind of
fun
Wings nachos dude that's a party that's
a
party TM said hi AOS I love your standup
comedy show slightly offended by your
software engineering takes though here's
the thing he misspelled offended he
probably wouldn't do that if he was a
real engineer you know what I mean he'd
probably probably throw on that extra
d all right look the Cowboys are getting
the ball back maybe they can actually do
something with it Aaron cre said we need
to get Andrew in here watching with me
maybe we will one day here's the problem
he don't really watch much football
that's the issue with getting Andrew in
here guys we
are two10 of the way through this game
probably mathematically speaking So 20%
down 80% to
go NS envo said do I hate San Antonio no
I do not I think San Antonio is much
cooler than Austin and didn't get any
credit for it so I like San
Antonio what are my thoughts on Seattle
that's a miserable place I see why y'all
kill yourselves hella board what's
up yo downtown Seattle actually was
fired to be fair my the shows I did like
a year ago we're in Tacoma and that was
rough Seattle it was first of all like
cold in like June I was cold wearing a
jacket in a hoodie but downtown Seattle
was really pretty I will say that I take
back all
I take back what I
said oh my brother just texted me he's
watching what's he
saying
unnecessary I got to come to BC I dude I
was in Vancouver I was in Vancouver last
year I think and it was the drunkest
show I've ever done in my life not me
drinking y'all also Vancouver Indians
are really odd they'll call like there
was a kid named rubby he's a comedian
very funny kid I forget his last name be
honest with you because all I remember
is that he called himself Ravi he called
himself Ravi who is Ravi and all of his
Indian friends were like yeah Ravi that
was the weirdest [__] I've ever seen in
my life dude Ry rvy if you want to be
really American which I am pretty
American but Ravi what is even that what
the hell is even
that y'all seen that video what the hell
is even that it's one of my favorite
it's one my favorite internet videos
daddy chill look it up right now while
it's a commercial break fantastic can we
pull up Med on here yeah we're about to
pull up the greatest clip all to find
the short
one this is fantastic
dude okay was trying to pull it up on
the screen right now IG you could be
getting in this on YouTube but I like
that the numbers are
climbing here you go 21 second clip can
they hear it or do I need to turn off
the TV to make sure it's on screen first
okay Kev is doing big things over here
dude we're figuring it
out
ready oh the game is about to start dude
maybe we do it at the next commercial
okay next commercial we're going to get
this going IG live you want to go to
YouTube you can watch one of the great
one of my favorite clips of all time so
goddamn funny dude also again shouts to
priz piix for sponsoring this priz
pi.com promo code akos match your
initial deposit up to $100
cidd lamb dude I'm going to hit on that
priz pick I said cidd lamb more than 74
and a half yards that one's going to hit
boys anytime a receiver cries he's going
to get the ball the next week that's
just a rule of thumb and I like CD lamb
and I'm glad he cried he needs the ball
more but if you complain as a receiver
and you're good you're getting the
ball he's got 50 yards already dude
first quarter I'm looking
great I wish I could have tripled up
that prize pick oh Jesus D oh hey Dak
evated a
sack oh my goodness he just ran for
another first down if you did prize
picks Dak yards rushing you already
would have
won if you did more you'd have won right
there ah man who have th how's the chat
looking in the YouTube C anybody funny
anything say anybody say anything
funny
com
wild which one what would I do to fix
the
war buddy the hell do you want me to say
that what the hell is even
that that's how I'd fix it I would go to
both countries and Go Daddy chill c your
wife just texted you I hope it pops up
on your laptop I can't ruin the man's
marriage for you know IG live
streaming this is a defense for the
Chargers
that
oh yo Jonathan just said aash I'm a
flagrant patreon member and listen to
every F today I tried Indian food for
the first time because of you spicy
chicken masala and garlic naan best food
ever you're the man buddy did you dip
the Naan in the ticka Masala that's I
saw the video that white kid trying
Indian food for the first time are you
[__] kidding me deck throw the
[__] ball
dude I just don't just throw it away
just throw it
away I mean just throw just throw it
away IG live if you're watching the game
Watch the replay of what Dak does he
evad the sack masterfully would have
been like a 15 yard loss and then
instead of just throwing the ball out of
bounds he keeps looking for someone and
takes a five loss
why could have run
didn't
well at least he got hit in the head you
know what I mean that's good you can do
both of those
things you know what I'm looking forward
to is watching this video at the
commercial
break a delay of game I mean I
just oh my God why would who cares about
the timeout just take the [__] delay
of
game
a sack and then a delay of game I
mean this guy's gonna make $60 million
next year I don't want to count a man's
Pockets but it's a fine out amount of
money to go around I noticed that let's
watch this
clip let me have this house let you have
my
house I your Tres on my property you
didn't wish my
y Daddy
chill what the hell is even
[Laughter]
what the hell is even that oh my God oh
my wife showed me that video is so good
dude it's my my maybe top five favorite
videos of all time there was another one
you got to have Tik Tok I think where
the wife can't find something and the
the husband goes honey open the freaking
doors and it's just so good you just got
to watch it it's I'm not I'm not going
to do the act out cuz that ruins a joke
but it's so [__] funny I I'll see if
I can send that to kf2 at some
point oh my god
dude hey guess what happened Dak tried
to throw it to Michael Gallup and it
wasn't complete because Michael Gallop
less always Michael Gallop less you know
what's funny is I that's a better camera
but I find myself looking at the phone
more often maybe because it's closer I
don't know the
difference boys only episode tomorrow no
they're in Europe how do you think we're
going to do that exactly Isaac I just
want you to put your thinking cap on for
a second take off the Cowboys cap put on
the thinking cap and ask how are we
going to do a Boys episode when they're
in Europe and I'm in New York City with
Alex just figure it out real
quick sorry I'm grouchy it's because the
Cowboys are
terrible AOS we need a solid guest list
it increases engagement I'll work on it
dude the problem is most Comics don't
know football Joey Avery knew football
Derek Poston knows football probably a
couple others but for the most part they
don't shocking I don't know what they
were doing obviously not as cool as me
virgin
31 cat baby gate but have the volumes
can we look up the cat baby gate video
it's 20 second video Dan devel just said
to look it up it's
hysterical hey what's up buddy knock
knock how you
doing hey thanks for still watching
Aaron appreciate you dude okay this it
25 seconds best cat jump ever cat jumps
over baby gate but volume needs to be up
he
said let me see if I can get this Roku
remote yo shouts to Roku for making
remotes that don't
work
that wasn't that good
dude I mean it's pretty good on the
replay cev you like cats how did that
feel to you is that
funny I'm gonna be honest dude I'm a
little underwhelmed what the hell is
even that is different oh Shan gillos
we'll get Shane on an episode dude
that's a great call J Victory we're
gonna get Shannon episode thoughts on
the Dylan danis fight I texted Dylan
after he did flagrant and I was like hey
man love you go win this [__] fight
we're friends and I don't I don't he
didn't respond and I've never been
happier that a person didn't respond to
my text messages ever cuz I would have
felt obligated
to talk to him after this fight and that
was a waste of everyone's life time
money that Dyan danis fight dude what
the hell was even
[Music]
that
butter Flores my brother he loves that
video there's a there's one Scarlet
Takes a Tumble that's
funny but what the hell is even that's
probably my
favorite hey Kev can you look up open
the freaking
drawers it's I think it's funnier if
you're in a relationship somehow and I
can't explain it but it is it has
nothing to do with being in a
relationship really
but and then I'll let you know if it's
the right
video yo the Chargers are at like their
own one yard line or whatever they great
field position great punt by whoever's
punting on the Cowboys I don't even know
anymore I forgot his name I Used to Know
It And now who cares
dude what the hell is even
that open the freaking door open the
freaking drawer oh
drawer and then let me see what pops up
so I can make sure it's the right clip
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah let's let's get
all on this one too yeah this one makes
me laugh
dude let's wait for the commercials I
can comment the commercials where we
need to kill more time frankly
frankly oh God damn it dude
no God damn
it who missed that tackle was it was
second
down Kenan Allen caught a six-yard pass
and turned into a 12 yard
game I don't even know who miss a
tackle two tackles
Miss yo is Justin Harvard throwing with
a glove or is that his off
hand
something happen in
Brussels somebody just asked the most
memorable advertisements of all time
I've said it like that because I assume
he's not American what are y'all
favorite commercials let's get IG in on
this also y'all can join the YouTube
it's a little easier for me to read the
thing what's your favorite commercial of
all time big Kev there was a got milk
one got milk had a run dude they were
selling us that [__] like it was healthy
with the greatest ads ever Southwest
Airlines got great ads
dude there's one where a guy is next to
a girl and he says something about how
he loves her or something and the girl's
next to him it's co-workers and she's
like oh my God I can't believe you said
that I love you too and then the guy
turns and looks at and he's wearing a
Bluetooth headphone and then uh it goes
want to get away it was great
great all right open the freaking
drawers dude let's do it
got to make sure volume is up dude
there's another one my wife you showing
me all the tick Tas I know I watch watch
watch open
freak it's so good dude it's so good
watch it again watch it again I know I I
I kep
finding open the
[Laughter]
freaking they getting up dude
oh my
God open the freaking
do oh it's so good oh my
goodness all
right oh my god dude did you got IG live
look up open the freaking drawers cuz
y'all are stubborn you not going to
YouTube it's so good man oh my God the
hands right the hands bro hands be
killing me
oh
God the Wasa commercial was classic dude
I never seen a commercial take over a
country like that that was unbelievable
and I remember watching
it like when it first came on cuz all I
did was watch TV that's why I'm not a
doctor and I was just like what the [__]
did I just watch but that was incredible
and then everybody was talking about at
school the next day like it was an
episode of Friends or Martin or some
[__] like that it was
unbelievable
someone said the beggars in Karachi
tackle better than the
Cowboys that's good dude they definitely
they're all over you man well I don't
know about Karachi but
India oh
goodness any other videos worth watching
dude open the freaking drawers that's my
Lane basically Fed Up white guys I love
it if I see a Fed Up white dude in the
commercial I probably I'm going to laugh
just fed up fed up with the
world Gatorade commercials did used to
be fire is it in
you my brother just asked if was up
originated from Martin no it did not
dude not that's was up was up was not
that was their own thing that they just
did was
unbelievable I'm telling you what I'm
about tired of Mike McCarthy I really
liked him until literally 7 days ago 8
days ago and now I'm about
done I'm a logical person
obviously all right second and five come
on just please bring him down God damn
it all right fair enough incomplete
passe Donovan Wilson should just be a
linebacker I don't know if you guys
watch football he's a safety but he
should just be a linebacker sorry I got
to answer some texts about sorry Canada
I got to answer some text about
tomorrow's
episode which one do you like
ke this one or this
one uh go to the other one
again this one right yeah that one's
good I like the blue of the other one
but are you [__] kidding
me are you [__] kidding
me you guys see what just happened pass
was batted down landed right back in the
quarterback's hands Justin Herbert and
then he ran for a first unbelievable
dude oh my
God what reflexes that was actually
really impressive on his part watch this
he sees it picks it up goes this guy's
great dude Justin Herbert's great I wish
he was a Cowboys
quarterback
I might have to do this one more time
maybe hopefully now but I might have to
do this one more time in terms of being
on my phone for a
bit know that they don't think they
really use that finger until it's
injured and you don't want to bang it so
you can
[Music]
all
right second and five again very
manageable let me tell you something
there's very few fan bases that are it's
fun to be that fan and
I 15 yard penalty there you go that
makes
sense
couple people asking me if I want Tre
Lance to get in yes I do I do I don't
care I
[Music]
do I don't understand when you see a
quarterback sliding what makes you think
that you should go for the
hit
hero I don't have any rupees bet on this
game but I got 50 bucks in prize picks
to pay off 250 if I hit again CD lamb
more than 74 and a half yards that's
looking great Austin Eckler more than 50
yards rushing I don't know if that's
going to happen and Brandon Cooks less
than 36 yards I think receiving that
probably also will happen Austin Eckler
is the one I'm worried
about
oh here we go here's a sec you know Kev
is a sweetheart dude cuz he's rooting
for the Cowboys just cuz I'm rooting for
the Cowboys what a guy dude he don't
give a
[__] let's see where the penalty
is I
[__] guys prize picks is playable in
California I believe unless you guys are
bigger cucks than I
imagined hey great great great right
there Sam Williams hands to the face and
no pressure that's good really get the
worst of Both Worlds
going I had faith in this team until
eight days ago you guys know that I had
faith I'll tell you what
man we need a guess cuz this is a
miserable experience for me just
watching this game by
myself anybody want to come over that uh
I would actually want at my house
probably
not this sucks dude why didn't I should
we might need to stop doing Cowboys
games I'm too emotionally invested in
this a miserable right
now Parson's almost got to your sa dog
that picked him to get one
sack that was a
drop first down pass should have been
caught to be honest with
you I know the 49ers lost and the Eagles
lost this should be a great weekend for
the Cowboys but only if they win and
it's seven all but the defense is
supposed to be good how are they get
this many
yards I know Justin Herbert is good but
n come
on
UFC stream is a great idea do we might
need to do a UFC I don't know nothing
about UFC but that might make it more
fun show us a join for that one unless
he's selling out an arena somewhere but
why do that when you could come to my
living room and watch a watch a UFC
fight on
pay-per-view Jay Victory asked me to
explain the cuck thing with C go to
California and it'll become very clear
that these are people who would love to
have someone have sex with their wives
in front of them while they watched it's
just a clear thing they'll just pick up
on that energy really
quickly honestly there was a lot of
pressure on those three plays I I give
the cowboys that credit I wish they
would run Austin Eckler a little bit
more so I could hit my prize pick cuz if
he gets the
ball I'm going to win I'm going to win
money
i' be down to a boxing stream too again
I don't know much boxing but there's got
to be a a boxing match worth doing and
often this is problem with UFC and um
boxing is often times Saturday night I
got shows so it have to be one where I
don't have
shows Cricket beauty of Cricket World
Cup of cricket 430 in the morning my
time it's on so I don't know if I'm
going to be up that early but I can
definitely watch a lot of the match with
the and it's like a seven eight hour
thing so we'll stream that world cup of
Cricket's going to
happen Bailey O'Neal said the Cowboys
need to score here look man I'm
miserable too but they don't actually
need to score at 77 but I completely
understand what you're saying being a
fan of this team sucks it sucks I don't
like it I wish I was born in some other
City imagine being born in like Maine or
something where you just pick any team
you want
to oh Fury and ganu was in two
weeks two weeks I have a show I think I
think in two weeks I have a
show yeah in two weeks I have a show
yeah Atlanta 27th through the 29th if
you're in Atlanta come
through oh hey any other videos we
should watch during the commercial
breaks send me your best viral video
I'mma watch him on
YouTube why I kind of look like Sid the
Sloth I don't know who he is but I'm
sure that was funny I'm going to give
you credit for that
dude yo Islam and vul vul got that Kev
you know UFC vul is gonna win this is
only 11 days he had to train um it's
going to
be closer cuz I think I was I was
listening to a pod that said uh people
think he's going to take more risks so
he might go for it a little bit harder
because he has nothing to lose at this
point now yeah you know um I think he
could do it genuinely I don't think he
was robbed last fight like everyone else
does but I think it'll be good if the
fight went a little bit longer it seemed
like he would have won it seemed like he
figured it out at the end of the fight
but yeah as it was I didn't have a
problem with I mean Islam is great
there's no saying I'm not saying he's
not great but I think vul man let me say
vul and Izzy are two are two truly good
dudes and that's so incredible because
they could kill you in seconds and
they're just the nicest guys and it's so
[__] cool that they're like genuinely
down to earth a lot of UFC guys are Max
Holloway
same those are the three guys that has
come to my mind first but in general
shikan was great you guys are great dude
they're I want to get more athletes on
flagrant they don't be coming on very
often but the UFC guys are always
great
last dude ay I want to get a on
something but these [__] are
always traveling somewhere it's
unbelievable are you garbage check out
their podcast it's great they ain't
never doing nothing outside of that
podcast though yo I can't believe the
Jets and Browns won they beat the Niners
and Eagles the undefeated teams the
Browns didn't even have their starting
quarterback hey look a flag already two
flags
unbelievable at least least the Cowboys
lost two yards with all that that was
good maybe it's offsetting
penalties illegal shift un [__]
believable I
just
who has been my favorite flagrant guest
AJ asked that question Michael
Irvin he was a great athlete and Izzy
those are the two and Izzy I love that's
I love him that's family but Iran was
also so fun that was my that was my
favorite athlete of all
time
hey you know what's a good idea on Third
and 10 is throw a 5 yard pass I think
that's a really good
idea that I just think I think that is
innovation right there third and 10 5
yard out route that's it that's the move
kind of a lot of what we've what we've
seen from this from this cowboys offense
when they you know it's third and long
and and yet they're throwing the quick
passing game and and they've done a lot
of it throughout this always a of what
has hey look another
flag guys this might be the last live
stream Cowboys game in the history of
this [__] YouTube
channel snap Kev hey guys give me
another good YouTube I mean a good
commercial what was the commercial that
we were pulling up someone said frog
Insurance seems all right let's pull
that up I have very little faith in this
commercial hey look penalties on the
Cowboys guys what a what a
surprise dip
[__] when am I coming to Dallas when
they win the Super Bowl that's never
that's when I'm coming also Thanksgiving
but I'm not performing I'm just seeing
my
family keep
it all right
geneng has been asking for this
commercial for hours it feels like and I
have no faith that it's going to be
funny but we're going to watch it it's
on the YouTube channel again IG also
shouts to prize
picks
milon Discover Card hey I heard you guys
can help me with frog protection yeah we
help with fraud protection we monitor
every purchase every day and alert you
if anything looks unusual wow you're
really looking out for us we are and if
there are un purchases on your Discover
Card you're never held responsible just
to be clear you are saying frog
protection right yeah fraud protection
frog protection fraud protection frog
fraud frog fraud I think we're on the
same page we're totally on the same page
at Discover we treat you one of the
stupidest commercials I've ever seen in
my life I'm going to be honest with you
am I wrong am I overreacting no no no
you're not that was chat was at terrible
right yeah yo ban them from the chat
temporarily that that's I can't believe
that was waste of everyone's time that
was the Dylan danis fight of this
stream that was unbelievable dude Jesus
Christ anything else what's up guys how
we doing over here look at that
streaming the Cowboys game right now
it's um it's a bit of a nightmare but we
keep doing this on pricee pick you know
what I
mean
yeah guys we're GNA get we're g to get
guests over here because this is you
know I I forgot that in commercials
there's nothing to do except watch
terrible commercials that are suggested
by chats Chatters what do you call the
chat the chat that's what I call
them you're
America Dilly Dilly was a funny
commercial I remember that one swept the
nation we don't need to pull that one up
though it's not worth pulling up but you
guys remember Dilly Dilly I
think thoughts on the KSI fight that was
also terrible I'm going to be honest
that was the worst three hours of
professional not even professional worst
three hours of any sport I've ever seen
in my life I have enjoyed watching my
niece's t-ball practice more than I
enjoyed watching that fight cuz at least
I you know kids are adorable so that was
there that's that
but watching a grown men not fight for
two hours was
unbelievable my Texas Rangers Fan
somebody asked that I'm watching now
just because they're doing well I'm a
fair weather Texas Ranger fan I'm not
going to watch one they're bad or in the
regular season because regular season
baseball's horrendous
but yo smile direct Club is still a
thing huh a I don't trust it I don't
know why it's cheaper than invisaline
but invisaline makes more sense to me
you got to meet with people once a month
just to make sure everything is going
okay Geneva has thoughts on United
Airlines I got United Airlines cuz I
just invested early in terms of like
that's who I was going to go
with and people on it but they're not
that I mean they'll kill a dog every
once in a while drag an Asian off a
plane every once in a while but they're
not that bad outside of that I mean like
I had I had delal it for a bit that was
not all as cracked up to
be I'll tell you I didn't realize Austin
Eckler had a high right ankle spring
that I should have probably looked up
before I picked him to get more than 50
yards I still think it's possible but
that's a little
disconcerting he's lined up to the off's
left they pitch it out there to let ands
try to run him down but a
lot all right second and seven this
is this is a big down right here for
this drive keep it third and long there
you go ah well that sucks that EA lost a
yard but there you go third and eight
that's a now you got to make him do
something this is not a Palestine jacket
dude [__] relax everyone is a ruby
Rosa shirt why yall trying to make me
get all political Ruby Rosa best
restaurant in New York
City Maris Bell should play more W th
Thomas should play more I don't know if
y the Cowboys fans are not but they
should play more I don't know why we
keep looking at Donathan Wilson and jron
C third down seven is a flag and I think
it's on
LA
and the pass is incomplete I have I
think it's on La and a penalty will be
declined I think I
think Bal wants to know the best movies
to make a grown man cry
Coco you ever cried at a movie Kev all
the time really yeah yeah off sides God
damn it
dude [__] how you line up in the
neutral
zone really seems so
easy uh what's your what movie do you
cry every
time um I cried at Marley and Me I cried
at Marley and Me holy [__] if you want
to cry watch Marley and Me holy [__]
didn't rewatch I guess but
uh I don't know emotional scenes get me
click that classic scene of Click was
like crazy when I was a kid I never saw
click no no oh damn Adam Sandler right
yeah he's the
best
oh all right little stand on third down
we were watching Harry Potter you
watching Harry Pot last night remember
remember uh at the end of the second I
think it's end of the second one you
cried at the end of the second Harry
Potter didn't cry but like you got that
part where you're like oh damn that that
was good is when they give Neville long
bottom 50 points or 10 points for just
his courage for standing up to his
friends oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
best Bollywood movie The Bollywood movie
that makes me cry k3g kbby Kushi kbby
gum I will I I watched that movie by
myself on a laptop like 13 years ago or
something and I paused the movie and
said in a room by myself what the [__]
is going on with me right now cuz that's
how often I was almost crying watching
that movie Coco you seen Coco Kev no God
damn it
dude Kev cried at Jurassic Park someone
said probably because you're your
brother the T-Rex almost
died I mean
water boy
fantastic ask were you the class clown
in school and what's funny about that is
that's like when we want to pretend to
ask a generic question in flagrant
Schultz will look at the guest and be
like so were you like a Class Clown
growing up or what that's that made me
laugh somebody cried at Cuba Gooding
junr punching the air boys in the hood
that wasn't cry worthy Menace to Society
cry worthy or when Ricky dies in boys in
the hood try worthy Menace to Society
that's a rough one dude that's a rough
one but in now knowing what I know Kane
dying is better than spending the rest
of his life with Jada pinket Smith so
that's actually probably a happy ending
when you think about it if you think
about
it happy
ending what's going to happen to will
what's he going to do he hasn't spoke
yet will no will spoke I think
he oh God what did will say will spoke
will will broke his silence on the whole
thing he supported Jada like a [__]
idiot obviously this guy could have just
married Margo Robbie and been
happy they said they didn't sign a
prenup and I think that's maybe that's
why they're still together but also just
give her the money who cares get her out
of your life dude she's a
succubus I cried all of Will's movies
now I don't cry at Will's movies but I
do cry when he comes on red table talk I
find that to be tragic
that's the [__] that's the Romeo and
Juliet of our day except you wish they
would both
die that was a joke for the record
don't will just wants to be a
sympathetic figure again it's a
marketing strategy that's the worst
marketing ever because nobody likes Will
Smith anymore so that's really terrible
marketing that's like being like hey you
know what I want people to love me again
why don't I I murder somebody why I
murder somebody that everyone loves why
I murder the pope that'll make people
love me it will
not Pursuit of Happiness not a crying
movie I didn't cry in Pursuit of
Happiness at all I actually didn't cry
at all in Pursuit of Happiness and I
kind of and I feel better saying this
now cuz will we realize will sucks but I
walked out of that movie being
like I guess man I felt like they were
trying too hard in Pursuit of Happiness
oh Cooks just got a first down holy [__]
dude I'm in danger of losing my prize
picks cuz Brandon Cooks
has 17 yards or something
now he's halfway to his prize pick over
his more or
less oh that's so funny troan just
addressed the fact that people say he
looks like white Jay-Z he just address
hilarious
hey Gallop eight yards you know what
that is two less than what you need for
a first
down C and Lion King Lion King is a
banger dude that [__] is a banger I oh
yeah Interstellar too my I haven't
watched Interstellar my wife rewatches a
lot of Disney movies Lion King I'm like
can we not it's too emotional for
me this is too emotional for me c have
you seen a lot of Disney movies Big C
hasn't seen many movies not a lot of
Disney no
what's your favorite movie have you seen
sha Shank Redemption no you would
[__] love that movie no I
haven't you would [__] love sh I love
uh you want to come on camera or you
need to be here oh I'm good I mean I can
be
wherever deadp Society made you cry in
high
school
gay I'm kidding it's a fantastic movie
rest in peace Robin
Williams
if Fat Albert was in that movie it would
be called pursuit of heaviness that made
me laugh I don't know if it should have
but it did it did
dude oh boy that's
a oh I think he roughing the passer
call
flag the
can I tell you something about big Kev
big
Kev might be the blackest person I know
he's white but ask Kev if he's seen a
media movie and he has and he didn't do
it ironically he just seen it on repeat
my mom loves those movies his mom loves
media movies what's your favorite media
movie um I think probably one of the OG
ones di Mad Black Woman you like di Mad
Black Woman better than family reunion I
don't remember that one specifically
family re around the same time Shamar
Moore and he
had the braids or whatever that look
really
stupid media Goes to Jail great one
media Goes to Jail great I never saw you
seen him too yeah of course yeah I never
saw bu media Halloween though I stopped
at those three I saw those three and
then I
stopped all right first and 10 yeah you
got a 15 yard penalty this this is where
you capitalize oh my God are they
throwing down the
field Michael Gallop less dude Michael
Gallop less always Michael Gallup BL I
don't care what it is Michael Gallup
BL I'm trying to be less fat so I'm
dring oh that was a grab but he still
should have caught
it yo troan and I just had the same
exact
thing second and 10 handoff three yards
that's great that's what you like to
see that's what you like to see right
there not the best play call but at
least there was poor
blocking Cole Fletcher says diary Mad
Black is the best
one which one is the one with Kiki
Palmer That's goes to jail right I I
don't remember them specifically like
Google it I bet that one is good
too there's a scene where she just slaps
the [__] out of Kiki Palmer is very
funny very
funny the boiling hot grits in in family
reunion great
scene CD lamb first down on Third and
eight that's huge and I'm going to hit
the more on CD L it's not even a [__]
[Music]
question people are calling for Kev on
camera
dude honestly he might not fit on camera
CU he's so goddamn tall all right dver
Mad Black Woman family reunion class re
reunion I never saw Meet the Browns I
didn't care for ghost to jail I think
that was the one I saw I can do bad all
by myself I don't know if I saw that I
don't think I saw that these are all
Tyler movies not just media right yeah
this is Media the character that I
looked up oh okay media homecoming might
need to get watched that came out last
year maybe that's something we live
stream if we can we just all watch media
homecoming as a family that would be so
funny
right they're like Bollywood movies and
maybe that's why I like them there's a
lot of
melodrama it's a lot of you know just
scorn lovers or whatever like you know
terrible husbands it's family stuff I
think it's it speaks to my bwood look at
Tony Pard is nice
dude Kiki's in family reunion okay
that's my bad I don't know if I've seen
go to jail I think I have but Kiki is in
family reunion that's my bad Cole
Fletcher knows his media dude you know
what's crazy I met some black people
from Mississippi and they really did say
hello really I thought that was made up
yeah damn they were like hello and I was
like wow
way more fun to say hello than
hello yo Kev are you getting texts on
your computer um yeah check your
texts fourth down one you have to go for
it you have to go for it you have to go
for it if you don't go for
it thank god dude fourth in inches Dak
Prescott QB sneak all you got to do all
you got to
do Oh
my he got it I think he got it yo you
got to give it to
him I don't think his knee was down I
think he got it Joe Buck I
disagree wow that's crazy you got to
challenged
that I think the eag are the only team
that's figed it
out dude his knee doesn't go down what
are you talking about oh it does go down
son of a
[__]
switching gains you don't e wear the
pants in your relationship you know what
you got to do start streaming the game
get a sponsorship from prize picks now
you get to watch all the football you
want to it's really fascinating how that
works out you I mean that it's work what
I'm going to do is it
work I got to be up at 7:30 tomorrow I'm
doing a panel for advertising and I
think it's hosted by Amazon or something
I don't know what I'm going to tell
these people
something about marketing I don't know
I'll figure it out I guess I hope one of
them is watching this stream because I
have not read the list of questions they
gave me to ask I maybe we'll read that
on the stream just don't tell anybody I
did that commercial break I'll read you
the questions whatever they are I
haven't looked at them yet half time's
coming up oh oh that's a fumble oh come
on it wasn't a fumble but I was hoping
it'd be a fumble God that would have
been
greated
said clicke clacky Kevin over here was I
know he has some big ass hands dude what
can you do you also used the wrong he
it's
H coach coach is a good movie but it's
not as good as
ddlj ddlj was first too so you know
whatever all right second and 10 two
minute two-minute offense make a stand
see if you get the ball back do
something with it
oh son of a
[Music]
[__] two minute
warning guys this is
terrible is three happy 3 three I
thought it was
tomorrow oh no it was the 15th what was
never three Hindu holiday Christian's
birthday I believe uh okay here you go
advertising week 2023 panel
questions moderator I won't say her name
guests other people and
me oh God all of you had taken the past
Les Less Traveled by in-building your
businesses I don't even know what that
means what is INB building your business
business please chat let me
know all of you have taken the path list
traveled by inbu building your
businesses could you talk about how
you've seen your respective Fields
change and what specifically prompted
you to embark on the entrepreneurial
Journey Matt McCoy said something shouts
to Matt okay does Matt watch football we
can have Matt over I just asked him he
said he's leaving Gotham you want me to
pull up yeah dude St hasely transed how
we support customers it's
buil guys if you don't know Matt McCoy
he's great and if you don't like him
you're not a patriot because he was a
veteran so you know whatever I support
the veterans what do you
do is he editing the special Cole cab is
editing my special singlehandedly I mean
I'm obviously going to have input and
whatever oversee the whole thing but
it's just big cev editing the whole ass
special so when it's fire because it
will be we had a lot of people do
everything beforehand filming and all
that stuff but C editing all Kev and
then me with notes that's about it Twan
operation okay second question can you
share strategies that worked
exceptionally well in growing your
audience and scaling your business as
well as those that didn't work you know
what is a great thing if you just yell
at people in the audience occasionally
as a British guy who's giving you an
attitude for no reason a British
homosexual and you yell at that
[__] that helps grow your
business if you can predict what part of
India Indians are from that can help
grow your business I could tell them all
of these things if you get a 7 foot
white guy to film all your content and
edit everything for you that can help
grow your business also a kid in
Thailand that got deported because he
was an illegal immigrant that could help
grow your business shouts to
CRI Trust in Media is a hot button issue
in today's digital age these are I'm
back to the questions by the way Trust
in Media is a hot button issue in
today's digital age whether it's
journalism or comedy how do each of you
ensure the authentic
I feel like these sentences could be
half the
words why don't people trust the media
that's it that's all you got to
say whether it's journal or comedy how
do each of you Ure they they added the
or comedy just because of me they did
not have I don't think I was their first
option for this panel cuz when they said
whether it's journalism or comedy and
I'm the only comic felt like they just
how do each of you ensure the
authenticity and reliability of your
content again that don't really apply to
me I'm
just I'm just talking that was a great
catch actually I I can't even hate on
that was a great throw great catch good
coverage by Don
Bland minute 30 and he got out of bounds
I don't know who this guy number five is
on the Chargers but he's nice yo okay
what advice would you give to content
creators aiming to start their own media
business lley could you give us a sneak
peak on some exciting new things you're
working on that one I got covered we're
going to talk about the special do they
care I don't know but I'm gonna talk
about it you know what I'm looking
forward to after this I got a Chipotle
bowl waiting for me fire hype about that
that I'm looking forward to this game 7
seven at the half I mean that's pretty
rough guys IG live the YouTube stream
we're playing commercials that are fun
there's a whole there's a whole it's a
whole thing going on so I'm on the IG
live to let y'all know about the YouTube
also Matt Matt McCoy War veteran is
coming over so if you don't like the
stream you don't like
America
soon someone said you're only where you
are because of your
physique yeah man that nothing has made
me feel like I have talent more than
that thank
you why don't I have a Netflix show I
deserve it num I thank you I appreciate
it
um that is a frustrating thing but also
have you seen most Netflix shows I think
I'll be okay flag on the play who Do You
Think This is on Kevin you don't know
much football but based on what you've
seen I didn't even see the just there's
a flag on the play you had to guess
who's it on
Dallas oh it could be offense it's on
the offense let's
go I don't know if I'm going be F should
I take this panel seriously I'll defer
to the chat if you guys tell me not to
take it seriously I will wake big Kev up
have him sneak a video of the panel of
me being a complete jerk off and we can
have some fun but I need at least like
20 30 people to tell me to do it and
then I'll I'll put a little YouTube
short oh that was crazy he had this man
in a headlock straight up choke
hold rear naked choke not have had like
a rear naked choke I don't know
UFC that's decent 5 yard game second and
20 that's all right he's out of bounds
fine let me open for you whenever you're
in Gary
Indiana I mean maybe if I'm in Gary
Indiana Rulo send me a tape and it
doesn't have to be great I just need to
know send me a tape now and a tape
whenever I'm there and if you've
improved substantially I will give you
time I'm serious DM me uh link and keep
DM me if I don't respond I don't always
respond to my DMs because you know I'm a
married man what good can come from that
for the most part but I will check your
clip and then whenever I go to Gary
Indiana hit me up again with a new clip
and if it's clear you've been putting in
work I will put you on
stage oh nicely done
Cowboys it would have been great if they
stopped a little bit earlier they only
have a minute left in two timeouts maybe
one two timeouts but that's fine you can
get the ball back you get a field goal
you're doing something who is that Dante
Fowler making up for his uh you on
fraction on third down
earlier got his
arm that might have saved
points yo being a gunner on a punt would
be kind of fun all right
tpin there's two Dallas Cowboys in the
last two years that during the preseason
all Cowboys fans were like this guy is
going to be
electric and then they just didn't
really do much of anything kavante
Turpin is won last year didn't do jack
[__] had a couple good punt returns but
no touchdowns and this year Duce Von the
little guy so excited about him healthy
scratch today didn't play at
all a message from Chad gbt aash your
insights are as profound as they are
hilarious ever thought about doing a
deep dive into the crossover between s
up culture and social commentary CH gbt
is thoughtful dude that was thought
hey guess what happened you threw it to
Michael Gallup and it wasn't
complete CD lamb dude keep it CD lamb
just go to CD lamb that's it that's all
you got to
do mlan Show on Netflix wasn't funny
melany didn't have a Netflix show did he
he had a fox at come back in the
day he had a special on Netflix a few of
them that I've heard were
good CD lamb he just hit the over I'm CD
lamb more than 74 and a half yards I'm
pretty sure I'm right now I'm done
that's
done that was actually a great pass by
deck
84 yards did it got more so now we just
need Austin Eckler he get 50 yards and
Brandon Cooks to keep goinging Brandon
Cooks has been doing which is getting
ignored by his quarterback and then I
just bet $50 by I just put down $50 at
Price picks won
$250 good catch oh Michael Gallup got a
first down Michael Gallop more
unbelievable second catch on a sixth
Target but whatever first
down
Prescott's line is not bad 13 for 18 143
yards flag on the play probably a hold
it's not the
best checking in on Matt McCoy right now
and it is just that
he said he'll probably be here in 25
minutes okay that was it that was five
minutes
ago he's going probably be here after
halftime after halftime that's great
halftime is 12 minutes that's
perfect yo who is that on 73 or
708 I didn't see
I think it was on Terence steel which to
be honest the guy's off a torn ACL I
don't even know why he's playing he
should just he's going to struggle this
year I think and he just got a contract
extension kind of
sucks there you go use a timeout use a
timeout helmet to
helmet 15 yard penalty right there let's
go you're get three yards out of
this that was unnecessary
roughness that was unnecessary that was
rough and it was
unnecessary what up
y you know what I'd love to have over F
but he doesn't know [__] about football
I went to a concert my homie fut doe f a
t so fire rapper concert was so good Kev
I wish you had come dude I know he was
in New York some venue in Brooklyn I
forget what it was called but such a
such a good show so
impressed is the chat still getting um
is it still
active use a timeout I don't know if
that was actually a terrible pass I just
don't understand why you just take a
shot at the end
zone son of a [__] that's one of my
favorite ter son of a [__] hey who said
that I missed it but son of a [__] i' be
saying
that honestly even if they don't know
about football is not a problem belal
all right should I invite over F I
already invited over M Mt McCoy we don't
have enough mics for three people you
wish you said that earlier dude I wish I
had said the f thing earlier
honestly yeah we could have had fun dude
next time he's in New York we'll bring
him on a live
stream PA got more receiving yards yeah
[__] I thought about doing that one too
I'm a white doing white dude mcing an
Indian wedding any advice
you got that man I'm gonna be honest
with you I assume you know the groom and
bride well enough um you didn't even
take a shot at the end zone
Cowboys
yeah yeah what's going on here figure
out the
clock Jo said get F if I didn't already
invite Matt McCoy over I would get FTE
but we don't have enough mics for three
people that's my bad that's my bad and I
think he might be in the studio guys
check out F there f a t h d OE on
YouTube or just I think just F the I
think it's F the doe on IG as well so
good what the hell is going on they just
took 5 Seconds off the clock for no
reason whoops I'm trying to pull up F
[__] to show it right there that's it so
good
dude and he's got an unreleased track
that he sent me that I I made him do at
the New York show so good it's
incredible he hasn't have a name for it
yet but whenever he does come out with
it I'm going to help him shoot videoos
for and stuff we got
that all right it's halftime guys here's
the options for halftime I could
pee I could eat some food I can eat in
front of you but that seems like you
know I don't know how these guys do Hey
Kevin what is a Kai sonat do I'm I'm
clearly the next Kai he just eats on the
yeah W that's vulnerable that's very
vulnerable Fame which one is
fame
fame didn't we use
that 100 Bund is my favorite sa Bund b a
n d
e oh look at that Fame there it is are
we allowed to play it went to say you
because I had a cancer T I actually
found out about F from my wife after
this song This Album came out so I don't
know a lot of his older stuff my wife is
my plug for all things Dy to be honest
with you without her I'd be even oh yeah
we heard this one yeah yeah no this this
goes hard
dude swagged out that's my boy right
there that's my
[Music]
brother we can play this without it
getting flagged it's YouTube right
should be good YouTube YouTube If the
clip like it could get flagged once it's
a clip but we
can yeah and plus it's him he'll approve
it can I tell you guys something Ryan
Clark is great I would love to have Ryan
Clark on the podcast if anybody knows
how to get in touch with this man I
would love to have pivot on flager
there's so he's great on ESPN I think
he's great as podcaster he's an athlete
who is honest without being
disrespectful even though tuos felt a
little disrespected by him and then he
apologize for it you know who else is
great Andre Hawkins great that guy's
great that's my
guy he's my guy just because he follows
me on Twitter but also I think he's
great at what he
does yo Colts Anthony Richardson the
quarterback for the Colts is out for the
season off the shoulder injury that's
crazy you know what's crazy as a philly
hater an eagles hater where are their
season ending injuries that never seems
to happen to them I want to say I want
to say that about San Francisco but last
year they got beat up as [__] but this
year they're healthy but last year they
got torn up the Eagles just scathed the
whole year unscathed two three years in
a row it's
crazy Dak Prescott's foot damn near fell
off guy can't run anymore where that's
not I'm not wishing that upon the Eagles
but it's just shocking it hasn't
[Music]
happened the only thing that hurt the
Eagles is uh
[Music]
the Jets believe it or
not okay so I got to pee guys well Kai
doesn't take the stream with him when he
pees
right that's not something he does oh we
looking at
[Music]
Twitter oh this is the troyman
doubleganger I mean it's uncanny dude
JayZ really uncanny is in the house
tonight reaching for a refreshment yeah
there's a meme that's going around
people think that's My Doppelganger you
know me and JC you how about I how
about that is very confident of of Troy
to say Jay-Z is his doubleganger hey can
we do we have the game can we get the
game streaming on on the YouTube what
game this this yeah I can try yeah we're
going to try to get the game streaming
on YouTube while it's halftime and we
can afford to take some do some
experimenting but no I'm not getting
high again Jose I got high on
yesterday's podcast episode with Blau
and Trevor and I I just don't want to do
it two days in a row and I did it last
week even doing it two weeks in a row
for me is a bit much because I'm a dork
but uh I can't just keep doing that on
streams I mean you know what the hell
would I be
doing price picks ain't paying me that
much I mean
and yeah I know Trent Williams CMC and
dbo were injured but I saw a thing on
the ticker I didn't say tell y'all but
it said uh dayto day so I felt like
there weren't real injuries and the
49ers do get injured the Eagles never
get hurt it's
unbelievable Jason Kelsey 108 years old
guy still plays every
game Jaylen Herz gets thrown into all
defensive lines he gets shoved into
defensive Lines by his own teammates
gets up every time
unreal all right guys I'm going to go
I'm going to go
P stick around take 45 seconds tops I'm
not going to wash my hands that
thoroughly I'll be back and then I might
get Chipotle I don't know maybe we'll
wait for Matt McCoy and then I'll make
that decision maybe I'll just have some
Quest chips or something hold me
over PE a lot guys
sorry
here
I just spiled Zia everywhere too so that
happened all
right I need to get a towel now cuz I
spilled a bunch of [__] my
bad
okay
[Music]
you
all right now I'm back for real and I
got Quest
CHS yo the numbers done went up as I was
peeing ain't that crazy how the YouTube
numbers go up do they go up or they went
down while I was peing do people love to
see me piss I guess
[Applause]
still someone asked if I sit down while
I pee hell yeah quite often actually me
and Larry David got that in
common
can you believe the Cowboys are winning
this game and it's 10 to
S and both teams scored in the first
quarter
early what's this K you kind of watch
the game
yeah yo I think Kev was going to figure
this out going to be watching this game
on
YouTube you need my YouTube TV right
there no cuz it always doesn't
work hell
yeah
allow we going to get this we're going
to get this stream up
boys
IG live check out
YouTube we're going to get the stream
going you're going to be able to watch
the Cowboy game with
me wait is that on look at that dude now
we're manning cting at this point this a
Manning
cast I'm a Manning I know football Omaha
Omaha I'm fairly certain pton Manning
was an investor in Omaha Stakes or
something if anybody knows that let me
know but I just feel like this guy was
always advertising for everything and
him saying Omaha could not have been for
free that often your first
home my sock is wet because I spilled
zeia and I got on my
sock and and I don't want to leave again
to go get a dry sock so I'm just going
to I'm a warrior dude I I play
injured I am like Tom Brady when you get
down to
it everybody's telling you how illegal
it is to do what we're
doing is it
illegal I don't know yeah okay it's a
light yeah yeah well I mean let's not
get this video taken
down what if it's YouTube and YouTube
though I got YouTube TV and NFL Sunday
Ticket let's not let's take this down
okay yeah I
am taken it down don't
worry that seems stupid
though we got to look into this it's got
to be a work around why I got YouTube TV
and Sunday Ticket I can't stream the
game on YouTube
what's
that I have to be partnered with whom do
I have to partner call us yeah that's
yeah we got
to do you have a person at YouTube H you
have a person at YouTube or no no I
don't have a person at YouTube I should
9 45,000 Subs
yo tell people to subscribe to my
YouTube let's get me to a million I'm
right there I'm knocking on that
dough I want that gold plaque if I get a
gold plaque I'm going buy two of them
one's going to go here I one of my
folks my mom when I say my folks I mean
my mom
obviously you know what I mean I'll give
it to my
folk what's up sick congrats on getting
engaged
dude y this guy keep saying Daddy please
on the YouTube chat IG we I pulled up
this video video what the hell is even
that it's a 20 second video or so you
got to watch it it's so
good
oh Tracy brought up why because instead
of paying for YouTube TV or whatever you
could just watch My Stream and watch the
game that way okay like
um you can you can look the video and
like do little things to get YouTube
like their their software to not pick up
that it's like an NFL game you can like
put music under the audio so it can't
pick it up but C has workarounds we
can't get it this week not something we
should play with we should find someone
to talk to oh yeah we should talk to
somebody instead of me getting banned
from YouTube right before I hit a
million Subs that'd be
[Music]
stupid
what's up guys ready to start the second
half oh [__] keev done got us a green
screen that's
fire this wall is going to be gorgeous
next week I don't even know but to put
it on
you quest chips
William belal yo this is a fun question
belal ask what's the most privileged
thing to complain about this week this
obviously a
crazy week in the world what's the most
privileged complaint you can think
of my wife got mad at me because I
forgot they get lettuce and for Chipotle
Bowl I feel like that's pretty
privileged or I'm just you know really
sloppy when I do favors for people but
you know both could be
true
antig my
guy Antigua
Antigua oh that was a great catch dude
who is this
guy okay setting up the green screen
right now dude we're gonna we're gonna
bring you some
backgrounds
dick is in my face I should
move how good say hi to Big cab guys
611 what was the was the penalty
holding we got green
screen
okay right
now
these Quest chips got too much flavor
privilege that's
good I'll tell you what's
privileged but we all do it when the
Amazon Prime don't get there on time and
you complain about it this week that's
the most privileged thing you complain
about and we're all going to do it going
two days shipping don't get there in two
days or one day shipping takes two three
days it drives you crazy but it's the
most privileged thing you can complain
about I don't know if y'all do this
y'all drink the bottom of the chips but
I do it I'm a fat
boy oh second and 15 is that
complete who is this kid Palmer dude he
is nice does anybody know who he is
anybody watch actually watch football
here hero Kev is 611 dude he is tall as
[__] I'm telling
you here you go
ready I got got on my
[Music]
shirk Carlos is very gas by what you're
about to do
Kev I'm just GNA snap some backgrounds
this guy's a genius y'all don't even
know
he's like a big ass Rainman you think
he's [__] but he got
it Austin Eckler only has 21 rush yards
but he only needs 30 more to to win me
my prize
picks as long as Brandon Cooks doesn't
get another
catch
that's a gain of three maybe
two you know who just texted me real
sick that's another great rapper Battle
Rapper though he who raps also but
battle rap
fire Joe Buton is a fan and Joe Buton
hates Indians so
that tells you
[Music]
something B complain as Uber drivers
asking me to come to the lobby and yo
that should be annoying
[Music]
me the elevator has been out in our
fourth floor walkup at the
studio and that
that has been pretty privileged I've
been so annoyed after walk up three
flights of steps to get to the fourth
floor every time I'm like you gota be
[__] kidding me
dude oh yeah I need to I need to know
this punch punch line Akash do you know
who Eileen is who's
Eileen get it it's right there hurry
up my store my grocery store doesn't
have keto hot dog buns that's
fantastic that's
great you know it's good to see San
Diego getting calls too and I don't
think the refs are biased just nice to
see both teams being sloppy six
penalties each there you
go I lean back as you suck on this dick
that's good
dude oh
man oh that's
good we got a green screen behind me
there's no Graphics yet but we're going
to get there iig won't be able to see it
though right it's just for the
YouTube look IG you there's a whole
different background here if you're if
you go to the
YouTube shouts to prize picks by the way
I'm looking all right on my prize picks
I just need Austin Eckler to get some
[__] rushing yards
[Music]
honestly if the Cowboys lose but I win
$250 that's nice that's
Solace matter of fact I might win
300 I think I'd win
[Music]
$300 yeah I think I would wi yeah three
picks to pay 300
look at that I put 60
down
man Michael Parson's no sacks yet that's
whoever his price pick was more than
half a sack not looking not looking too
great right
now all right second and
eight this is they're in cowboy
territory so this is not good now
they're in the red zone
so Keenan Allen slant route 18 22 yards
whatever it was 19 yards here we
go oh boy
guys coming out of both halves really
really just terrible drives for the
defense Donovan
Wilson I
don't what am I missing because people
love him
[Music]
the screen the screen is still Green on
YouTube Sir Kev they're talking to you
right now uh I just fix it oh that's
batted down there you go
Demarcus what is it what's it look like
now uh it's just black I got to put
something it looks like inside the actor
studio right now
black what kind of music do I listen to
these
nuts Bollywood mainly to be honest with
you Indian rap f is fire sh is fire sh
is
fire Bollywood love
Bollywood and then
rap American American
rap all right second and 10 here we
go holy [__] how'd he get
that that's unbelievable he he turned a
10 yard sack into uh no gain
unbelievable was big Cav at the New
Brunswick show yes he was big Cav is at
all my shows for the most part I think
he's had to missed like two since he
started working with me that's it two
weekends that was a hell of a complete
dude this guy Justin Herbert is nice I
wish he was a
cowboy all right third and 10 here you
go if you can hold them to a field goal
it's a tie game no big
deal this is supposed to be so the
Cowboys old offensive coordinator Kell
Moore is now the San dieg or the Los
Angeles Chargers new offensive
coordinator and this is be like a big
Revenge game and so far not so much oh
well there that's a first down never
mind who missed that
tackle I mean square up
dude Donan Wilson I'm guessing oh no
Stefan
more
oh he was
short thank you Justin appreciate it
glad we get help all right fourth and
one Chargers are going for it this is
big yo the Cowboys make a stop right
here fourth and half a
yard they're going to do the QB
sneak can you just be Stout oh they're
not going to do it wow play
action broken up donon Bland donon bland
is one of the few defensive players
that's balling out this year still let's
go Cole said these are two pretty
similar teams and they are I've always
said the Chargers are like the AFC
Cowboys you always think they're going
to be good and they never really are
but you know
whatever I'll take that
oh he almost picked
that what's on the green screen right
now
J big Kev dude modding his ass off big
Kev just commented as me guys IG go to
the YouTube we got we got to we're
having green screen fun we're watching
uh viral videos what are other funny
videos Akash is Twin is the background
well I mean I wish I was that beautiful
to be honest with you she's a beautiful
woman yo Shaq looks fantastic
dude guys if you have questions for Kev
other than how big is his dick feel free
to ask and he's married by the way very
married super happily so don't be
disrespectful but ask questions
did Matt McCoy take the train here oh
good question how utterly poor of him he
was at Gotham it's a 10minute
[Music]
drive yeah I love that Miss Melissa
mcarthy is still doing commercials with
her husband you guys know that guy in
Wedding Crasher that she's hitting on is
Melissa McCarthy's husband and they just
did a commercial together for
booking.com that's great God bless dude
can't put a pride flag behind him that's
actually really funny yeah he's doing it
right now dude he's on it don't
worry KSI versus Fury who won according
to you I think Fury won but it was just
awful I don't know it was I think we all
lost really there were no real winners
and we all
lost how many people in India do you
think are legit watching this game
there's 1.4 billion Indians so so easily
a millionaire watching this game just
has to be that's less than
1% you know what I
mean this was great coverage by donon
Bland Palmer
palmeran
BEC great
play thanks Shadow Bandit
you need a nap dog you right bro I slept
three hours last night woke up at 5:30
in the morning for no
reason flag on the play probably a hold
if it's a hold in the end zone that's a
problem but I don't think it
is honestly you hate seeing penalties
but this penalty will cost him like five
yards probably so that's not the worst
yeah declined was even worth
it can flagan try to do a pod with
Johnny Football we might have tried who
knows maybe we tried
maybe all right second and 10 all good
you're at the seven yd
line smart move declining the penalty
that was a three and a half yard penalty
and it would have kept their
down CD lamp let's
go why why run on second and
10 am I a pride flag yet K yeah it was
for a little bit oh
ni when am I coming to perform in
Phoenix yo get ready 2024 I will be in
Phoenix I want to say April Tucson or
Tempe whatever's closer Tempe Tempe uh
but I'm fairly certain it's April 2024
oh my God Prescott just got sacked on
third oh my God
sad dude just
sad I mean he didn't have any real time
to be honest with
[Music]
you all right Brian
anger that's a good punt actually
can you just just bring the guy
down Jack Wy I do not have a fantasy
football team I do prize picks which is
like daily Fantasy Sign up priz
picks.com promo code oash but that's all
I do right now my price picks Austin
Eckler's about to ruin everything by not
rushing for enough yards just break one
run and it's who cares it's
done
[Music]
people don't always know how to ask
Mar's background is
[Music]
funny any other
um Good YouTube videos to pull up Matt
McCoy is almost here by the way yeah
he's pulling up right now he's pulling
up
which is good cuz I'm tired dude I'm G
be honest this three and a half hours of
talking is
exhausting who thought who would have FK
watching football and talking is
exhausting that's probably why NFL
commentators is always two people now
that I think about
it Travis Kel is handsome
dude Travis Kel is people don't
understand why tlor shifters with him
are crazy this guy is handsome the
mustache thing was stupid yeah he looks
way better with a beard than a mustache
but you know maybe he just got tired of
being so
handsome dude I don't know how streamers
like Kai do over 10 didn't Kai stream
for 30 days straight yeah that's
Insanity yeah but honestly he'll just
sit there and be reading through Reddit
just look at popular videos on Reddit
it's just reacting to
huh what's the fanciest cheapest
cheapest anniversary date you can come
up with if you guys met when you were
younger you probably didn't have a lot
of money so what you do is you recreate
your first date because probably it
wasn't that expensive it's super
romantic and it's cheap most likely if
you went all out on your first date
that's kind of crazy cuz where do you go
from there but if you
didn't my wife and I's first date was a
haunted house $5 for a ticket and then
we ate at a restaurant in Philly called
Sam pan wasn't that nice wasn't that
expensive good food done recreate that
exactly you might have just given me an
idea
yo Jimmy Johnson greatest Cowboys coach
of all time no disrespect to Tom
Landry man I wish you was still the
Cowboys
coach Hayden said thought you'd like
Cricket I do why can't I like both
Sports and basketball these are the
three best sports on the planet distant
fourth is soccer or football whatever
you guys call
it actually know fourth is tennis and
then fifth is football
soccer that's Matt McCoy guys if you can
kev's gonna get it so I don't have to
leave you
again
all right guys halfway through the third
quarter 65% of the way through this game
we're doing it man we're doing
[Music]
it second and
eight two yard pass that's all right
that's fine that's
fine feeding it to Ferguson I need
points I'm sorry you picked Jake
Ferguson in fantasy my guy I thought he
would have a great year too he did
not I don't know that okay I'm upset I
read that message KSI vers Fury I
address this on YouTube I think uh Fury
won if you had to pick but in reality we
all lost for ordering that fight and
watching it everyone lost
Zam
McCoy oh my God if there's another 12
men on the field
penalty oh Dallas took a timeout to not
get a 5 yard penalty what's up
Kev someone said AA just AC accepted
Cowboys suck harder than a republican on
Epstein's Island
it's very true they're not good I know
this I realize this
now you's here happy barking y I'm going
bring happy in next time for the stream
[__]
pan oh yeah I forgot they both had stops
inside the Red Zone on fourth down crazy
how evenly matched are these
teams
Cowboys defense best pass rush in the
league we thought zero
sacks and I don't know how many they had
against San
[Music]
Francisco Matt Matt
McCoy guci baby what's up buddy do buddy
how you doing grab a seat who doesn't
love gas station Sushi boys I love gas
station Sushi I mean I once paid $50 in
Supermarket
to
Cado looks Brown so it's probably been
sitting for a bit I mean this morning
probably but that's all good yeah we're
going to we're going to ride it out
though y let's let's do this here we go
rock it
out
okay look at that huh I well we might
need to Y look how tall this
[__] is I don't even make
sense my bad Kev that's my
bad what is it a salmon avocado roll
salmon avocado dude bust it open let's
see what it tastes like it should be
yeah let's see who's going to take a
[__]
first 107 all right we got a game this I
mean it's really poor it's awful
football to be honest with you has it
been bad it's just been yeah just been
bad lot of penalties is it
it at the Chargers yeah all right but
the fact that you got 10 s Lead with
them on the road I mean that's you know
in the charge of a pretty good team are
you a big football fan especially Matt
is from Kansas City only people doing it
right right now we're going to be honest
so this is a great time to be a football
fan were you always always always been a
chief fan we're doing God's work right
now to be hon dud you're the best I I
for you all we uh I really do beating
Philadelphia was you did me a huge favor
yep huge favor my wife there's a video
it's very cute but she's on the couch
just singing that [__] Eagles fight
song during the ners game oh yeah I
forgot just she's a she's a Philly yeah
every every person in Philly knows that
s they singing at weddings I mean
they're just such
Apes they are bad people let's be honest
it's unbelievable they're not
humans all right first and
goal so you know not looking great let's
be honest here the Cowboy season are you
still a Believer no you're not you're
fully out Francisco was a huge I really
picked them to go to the Super Bowl and
then the San Francisco game just washed
all belief away from me and this game
has confirmed
that I mean your chargers are good
though they're not that good they're too
they have potential to be good that's
but they're the Cowboys in the AFC they
always have potential and they never are
great great comparison actually they
never are I'm going to be honest with
you I would I would encourage you guys
to try this but I'm okay I don't know if
you want you want to see can you show
you want to show the camera what it
looks like yeah I mean this is it's not
have you had a piece yet yeah I had one
and it's um it's what you think it would
be yeah it's exactly what you think it
would be all right I don't know if you
guys can see this this one yeah there's
starting to be brown around it the the
oh hilarious the green screen is
affecting it really Jesus that's so
funny yeah I mean the the rice is just
hard hard and criminal take off the rice
eat the salmon in the middle I could but
how you're potentially going to really
but ooh that's a bad run yeah but he
doesn't run much huh third and goal all
right here you go if they don't gain any
yards here I don't think they go for it
and then you could a field goal it's a
tie
game lot of time of possession for this
whole half I think Dallas has run the
ball I mean this whole quarter I think
Dallas has had three offens all running
Dallas has had three offensive plays La
drove it all the way down they had uh
Dallas defense had a goal line stand
yeah not goal line but fourth down stand
whatever very close then went three and
out then punted it La got the ball the
Dallas 49 and then driving it again
they've had the ball for probably 13 out
how do you feel about her is Herbert in
your head top five quarterback or not no
he's super talented but he's not top
five yeah he's got all the tools but
he's just not he's not it for some
reason he's not putting it together I
wish he was the Cowboys quarterback
though honestly still better than yeah
yeah yeah still better than deck and
honestly I don't understand it because
he has a lot of weapons I mean Allen uh
Eckler this guy Palmer number five i'
never seen before he's balling out of
his mind for the for uh for the Chargers
yeah I don't know who he is I don't
don't even know who's either that's our
division too I should know this I'm
playing yeah but you're so not
threatened by everyone in your division
yeah I'm really don't yeah just really
don't care about it is there one team
Joey Avery was here you know Joey Avery
Niners fan born and raised San Fran boy
are you worried about them in the Super
Bowl not really not really why not you
don't believe in Brock py I don't at all
me neither I don't I think he's going to
get exposed thank you I think he's going
to get exposed and the fact that they
think that he's the guy it's like how
many times have you seen somebody
remember when Kyler Murray was the man
had a great you remember when Dak
Prescott was the man yeah had a great
first year and you're just like but then
the defensive coordin figure him out
yeah and it's done yes yeah I think
party is just not the here's the one
thing I hear that is like okay maybe
that makes sense Shanahan just doesn't
need you to be a great quarterback
that's facts I mean he made Matt Ryan an
MVP yeah yeah no perect that's perfect
example he made yeah it was over after
he left yeah completely the guy's been
broken ever since so maybe he just needs
you to just do what I tell you to do
yeah eight- yard passes will take care
of the rest yeah so maybe and their
defense is crazy Philly do you fear
Philly I think Philly's the most
well-rounded team yeah on paper they're
they're crazy yeah I think the most
well-rounded team I keep saying this
though they don't ever seem to get
injured with that has to catch up with
them at some point and then Jaylen Herz
I think will regress I again yes I think
I think he's peaked and I think it's
only downhill from here he didn't
Mahomes on MVP last year right over
hers that's a good question I think he
did I think he did have you seen uh
quarterback on Netflix no but everyone
keeps telling me that I got to watch if
you guys haven't seen quarterback on
Netflix and you're interested in
football at all Patrick Mahomes is so
[__] amazing follows even off the
field yeah well it follows kurk cousins
Patrick Mahomes and Marcus Mariota who's
not that good kurk cousins is average
Patrick Mahomes is incredible and momes
when he's I mean no just as a
quarterback yeah and then he's just like
a he's just like a big church dork but
Patrick Mahomes on the field you hear
him talking [__] and it's so fire dude
do you remember that play where he uh
tell his stream he like it's like
against Tampa Bay yeah he they have the
like the 5 yd line of Tampa Bay he runs
he drops back almost gets sacked runs to
like the 25 yd line of comes back toward
the line of scrimmage spins away from
one Tampa Bay Defender jumps in the air
gets hit in the legs as he's in midair
horizontal he passes the ball scores a
touchdown in that play miked up he just
gets up doesn't even look at the
defender he just gets up and he goes I'm
like
that it's unbelievable I mean so it's so
That's So Gangster son I mean that's
that is him though like he's very um
cool as and cucumber like like uh just
like nothing frazzles the dude yeah get
fired up though yeah oh he gets fired up
which I like I actually prefer he does
that more to be honest you like
sometimes Kelsey carries that too much
there's another cool moment where he
gets in Max Crosby's face and it's so
fire I love that him and Tom Brady will
both do that they don't give a [__]
they'll get face I like that but there
is sometimes also like a a degree like
all right chill Philip Rivers used to be
like a little bit too aggressive you're
like all right buddy let's [__] slow
down dude I remember J Allen's got a
little bit of that in him too where he's
going after people like yeah he got
thrown around this weekend linan just
[__] I I want buff I would love for
Buffalo to win the Super Bowl I just
feel bad for the City of Buffalo I'm
going to be honest with you I agree and
it's weird to say cuz it's in the AFC
and like we have to see himin but I feel
bad for him and I almost want them to
win a little bit Yeah but I just don't
believe in Buffalo Cincinnati I weirdly
believe in more even though they're not
as talented yeah what about Jackson
Mahomes what Jackson Mahomes is a
[__] Menace oh dude you guys must
hate him in Kansas City they hate him
they hate him how do they feel about
Britney Mahomes they hate her too they
hate her too have you seen the clip the
meme of her the the have you her asking
Patrick mahomes's favorite cheat Day
meal no oh Patrick Mahomes oh when
they're interviewing each other and she
knows nothing about it just just this is
the funniest meme Patrick mahom Britney
Mahomes cheat Day meal
yeah yeah she knows nothing about her
own husband too they were asking him
questions back and forth she was going
like 0 for six and it was like babe have
you ever asked him a personal question
son my wife they sent me a video of her
bridal shower where they ask her
questions about me she's so spot-on
accurate and I'm so glad men would never
play games like that cuz I would have
gotten so much [__] wrong she knew
everything like the exact way wor the
sentence it was crazy and then when they
asked me I would have been like buddy I
don't know yeah I think it always weird
though if if the woman doesn't know like
okay we're going to play this at the
commercial it's so
funny yeah if the woman is not aware I
guess of like what the husband that
seems odd to me for some reason yeah the
guy should not know yeah yeah yeah I
don't know if that's just that's me no
that's that's the double standard as it
should
be oh Jon is live what's up
okay you ready we got a whole quarter
left Fried
[Laughter]
Chicken
no Fried Chicken no
chicken steak what is it po Mexican food
not even close not even in the same
hemisphere Fried Chicken is so funny I
mean God just a lack of awareness lack
of awareness and and and was so set on
chicken too for some reason went back to
back with it yeah that's what made it
more racism just keeping it chicken
yeah I mean I don't know I just don't
like her in general for some reason she
does seem annoying very annoying I I as
part of me was like maybe we're just
being too hard on
her some kind of Aly and he's married
somebody want her to shut up but yeah I
originally thought that too happy happy
hey this is
happy happy what's up buddy what's up
buddy what's up my guy guys this is
happy for those of you who haven't met
him I a real legend a real MVP as some
would say yeah look at him he's the best
he's the
best yeah what's up my guy Fried Chicken
that's the best man I want to implement
that in everyday want to know like the
top quarterbacks how many of them are
married I'd love to know like the top 10
like the top 10 best quarterbacks Brady
got married Midway through his career
right okay what about Josh Allen Josh
Allen's girlfriend not married okay Kurt
Cousins married he's not top Joe burrow
Joe burrow no bro that guy's out there
dude is he out there he's in the street
let's look let's look it up Joe burrow
Joe burrow might be in the streets
somebody asked if you watch Boxing
earlier you don't watch Boxing but you
do watch MMA correct I yeah I'm fairly
casual on both though this guy knows
fight Sports this guy boxed almost box
the Olympics yeah he' got his ass beat
if we're being honest about what
happened in the Olympics
but I would have taken a fat L I would
have take a fat Britney Mahomes is what
would
happened y look at Michael Irving dude
greatest FL Michael Irvin you has had
him on he's the greatest is he was he is
as advertised F unbelievably funny yeah
I figured oh that's called Jimmy
great um what am I looking up oh yeah
Joe bur girlfriend no way no way I just
called no way on
that my only point being I wonder if all
the top most of the top guys are
single I wonder if has anything to do
with it oh oh that was great play WoW
hey buddy I mean you got to oh my
goodness oh my goodness he's about to
get hit though yeah oh wow if he would
have win at he would scored that was a
hell of a play Third and
11 that was actually a good play by Dak
he that was that was momes like Escape
that let's
go look at that little
faki little cross the body nice break
the
tackle very good run after the catch
that was an awful tackle yeah
somebody said bag secured Brit Mahomes
facts I mean that was that's what it
seems like so apparently Joe bur is not
single who's he with I'm looking up his
girlfriend from back in the day
Olivia holes maker I didn't stop the
stream did it
no oh no come on
dude bro is not single somebody says
yeah that's supposed to be his joint but
that's old old work young man I don't
know if I'm old now but that it'ss very
young I think that's old work yeah could
be let us know uh oh yeah's going to win
Islam or V Islam vul too I'm going to go
out on a limb here I think vul takes
this I don't think it's out on a limb I
mean it was a close first fight but I I
think I think vul takes a even on 11
days rest that's the only actually do
actually
do yeah I like I like vul a lot and I
like the fact I think it's the most Thug
thing in the world that he flipped
around 11 days now just like [__] out of
here let's let's run it back do you
think he do that because there's not
really anything to lose like if he loses
it's 11 days he loses yeah exactly but
it's but he won't get a rematch though
true if but if he doesn't get blown out
again people are going to want to see it
it's almost like Max and in buul where
people like they keep wanting to see the
matchup okay yeah you know what I mean
where it's like it's it's close enough
that you're like all right listen until
until somebody actually has a dominant
win you're like all right that kind of
see if it's close I think my very
amateur opinion is that vul kind of
figured out Islam toward the end of the
match yeah and now he's got and that's
why I think he wants that's why that's
why he took the fight cuz he thinks I
think Islam realized that yep and this
is all kind of conspiracy theory is I
think Islam realized that and was like I
don't want to fight him again yeah and
then when his opponent pulled out I also
think the only thing that I think vul's
big thing is the is the gas tank crazy
gas tank I mean doesn't get tired
doesn't and so I wonder if he's coming
in if he was uh kind of in training and
kind of ready and still has that same
level of like go go go go or if uh or if
it's not going to be quite the same cuz
I think that's the biggest thing if he's
got the same gas tank as usual I think
he's got a good good chance apparently
got hand
surgery who vul I don't know he said
right after getting hand surgery but I
don't know maybe he's wrong I didn't
know that either he might not
have but yeah I haven't heard that damn
that's crazy I think he got hand surgery
right after the fight oh then he's good
yeah he know he does going say I he made
it sound like he was recent yeah I
thought it was respectfully about the
Paul Brothers I
mean
I you think you could beat Jake in a
boxing match they're big guys man
they're big guys Jake he know he's he
knows enough now that if he hit
Logan I don't think Logan's is good I
think Jake's definitely you think you
got Logan even jakee does amateur stuff
I was watching foot was coming off the
canvas when he was swinging against
that's I'm saying that like yeah yeah
yeah yeah dude what's going on Tony
turning it up this guy Tony can I ask
you when you guys when you let eeko
Elliot go were you fine with that yes
absolutely cuz you knew this guy was
going to come in yeah Zeke was just kind
of I love Zeke but it was it was time he
was done what's up buddy what's up my
guy his problems God damn it
Dallas you're not getting enough
attention guys you need both
something he wants something I don't
know what it is we're going to have to
wait till the end of the game Happy I've
got a live stream going on a live stream
we got a good game now people watching
on IG we
got got 10 10 score buddy we can't just
walk away from this I feel like happy
increases engagement though no abely
numers should go up y'all see this
little guy female engagement should go
up fast look at this little guy come
on how is happy six six it goes faster
and dogs age quickly
yeah oh how's wifey great she [__]
about to pop looks like she's about to
pop Matt McCoy's wife is pregnant
pregnan pregnant expecting I'm talking
to the kid now kids kid understands
kicking from the wom I'll talk to her
like it's kicking in the room and it's
like I hear you [__] it's a son or a
daughter yeah you [__]
n boy or girl uh I don't know we're
going to find out when oh that's right
that's right that's right yep we're
going to let it decide you know I mean
that's the kind of New York progresses
we are guys we're going to let it decide
you know what's up
buddy oh come
on thank you
guys are you [__] kidding
me I this is if I'm going to be honest
with you when I watch Cowboys football I
go they always find a way to beat
themselves yeah it's unbelievable it's
the worst team to root for really is is
it's just the most miserable team I
almost being a Jets fan this year they
gave you hope which is cruel but they
normally never give you hope it's fine
it is what it is don't even bother yeah
don't even bother watching go find
something else to do but the thing about
the Jets too and this is what I tell my
wife my wife is a Jets fan she like the
problem with them is that they'll always
find a way to [__] it up so it'll be
like they'll not make the playoffs but
then they also will go eight and n and
not get a good draft Yeah that's what
the Cowboys will do yeah it's just it's
pick a pick a line all right happy
you're messing up the mic now you good
here
buddy did is there a toy for him to chew
on or something yeah I think this is I
would offer him the sushi but he can't
eat
avocado the only reason boy no dog can't
have avocado or grapes or raisins
chocolate either chocolate dark
chocolate
especially he had a dark chocolate
cupcake one time we had to take him to
the hospital and they had to like induce
vomiting was crazy really yeah he's also
not big usually bigger dog can handle
maybe one yeah he was acting mad weird
running over the all over the house
let's
go let's go CD lamb I'm I I like CD lamb
CD lamb is great dude he was my prize
pick to get more they had 74 and a half
yards I said he get more
Austin now I I do the prize picks every
week they sponsor this bad boy nice
so do you also do uh what's it called
fantasy no I just do this fantasy's like
picking every week and stuff this is I
just pick two or three players and I'm
out yeah or four if I want to try to
make more money but it's like a
different bet every or a different
waiter every
week o that's a decent this is another
thing about the Cowboys I don't like if
be honest with you I don't necessarily
love their play calling all the time I
hate Mike McCarthy's play calling yeah
ha I feel like
um Jason was the same way though Garett
oh he was terrible Jason Garrett was
awful J the biggest problem with the
Cowboys is Jerry Jones he won't fire
people and he should fire them he won't
hire people and should hire them yeah
like if he had fired Jason Garrett three
years earlier maybe he could had Mike
chahan as a coach
yeah oh my
goodness wow Brandon Cooks with a
touchdown I thought Brandon Cooks was a
good off SE great pickup they just don't
utilize him now you got Gallup cooks and
CD lamb Gallup is not he's really
struggling this
year he's not doing much he's not doing
much at all interesting I kept saying
just earlier I was said my big gag is
whatever Michael Gallop Michael Gallup
is predicted just do less Michael Gallop
less that's your bet every week yo this
is a good question somebody said
thoughts on the Giants play calling this
week I didn't watch the game did you I
watched it last night yeah it was it was
awful I mean they didn't didn't get any
um help I mean buddy I'm so glad you
watched football oh in Atlanta we're
going to do a live stream I'm in Atlanta
10:27 through 1029 so before the Sunday
shows we'll live stream it yeah I mean
get a little setup the the just it was
awful play calling another thing too the
Giants I mean it does really seem like
sometimes like the commissioner is
calling in going let's let's figur it
out for for Josh Allen and the boys cuz
it's just like there was a play them in
the game with Wallen oh I saw that was
that was that's that was a that
passinger absolutely passive experience
even more so than the play before that
which got them to the one so that's was
like how is that you know not worse than
what we we already already seen yeah oh
yeah completely agree I saw the
highlights Killers the flower moon this
movie I it looks so good but I don't
know anything about it I just know it's
got Leonardo caert oh this is coming out
this week I'm going to see this Friday
yeah I'm going to see this Friday know
it is 3 and a half hours though who the
[__] wants to stay in the the the
there was like some Native Americans who
lived on land had oil and the government
came in and push them off their land and
took oil and was like giving them
residuals and then there was like
hundreds of family members throughout
the years by residuals you mean casinos
family they started killing the family
so the government had to stop paying
really the oil money so they would pay
less because they'd kill the family yeah
cuz they just got to a point where after
like dozens of years whatever it was a
couple decades no one left to collect
family members so they just started
that's crazy that's sad Al also tragic
ass movie I don't even know if that's
true but you said it and I believe that
honestly cuz like oh yeah don't question
this man he's a war
veteran also a hardcore conspiracy
there it it feels like there's a lot of
War veterans who are like that yeah cuz
they know how the government is man I
thought something you know what it is
Buddy like here's the thing
like so um Vanessa Gan was a girl who
got killed by the name like they didn't
really look look into it and it's like
it was one of our own like it happened
on a navy base and it was a crazy story
man and it they just didn't seem to care
or try to figure it out what happened
and there's always something like that
that's happened on bass there's like
there's um there's always something
going on with the dorms or or things
like that where there's like disgusting
stuff that's like or like burn pits all
this [__] and like they just they try to
hide it or they try to suppress the
thing so we're like man if you're
willing to do this to us you definitely
don't care about nobody else I see
saying yeah they also don't get yell
therapy which is kind of yeah that's
true too but you're working on that yeah
well buddy probably needs some more you
know I dude probably yeah
yeah
hi you want a therapy dog I want to get
one so I'm going to get a uh what's it
called when you um service service dog
I'm make it a service dog you're getting
a dog though
when after the baby okay after the baby
we were gonna get one before and then we
found out about the baby I'm like all
right we'll get one after so your wife
is cool with the dog Matt McCoy's wanted
a dog for a long time fighting him on it
for forever and I've been trying I'll
watch Happy dude three times a week
December if you're down we're going to
Europe for shows Christmas time got it
I'm would love to you're going to be
here I'm going to be here I'm going to
have a new baby and then happy you can
introduce the new baby okay perfect
December like 14ish we're going to leave
and we'll be back like New Year's Eve
day before you good with that perfect
I'm oh this is exciting perfect it' be
good training too yeah
facts initiate the uh he's the best do
look at him napping he's crying now he's
just
napping uhoh oh oh no oh wow you got to
hit that that's wide open yeah that's
the problem with him buddy you got to
make that
happen we saw the
goli this is
here's the thing about the
49ers speaking of them since you played
them last
week they didn't have Debo M mcaffrey
and Trent Williams and Trent and almost
still managed to get a dub this week
yeah but they were playing a Browns team
without their best tackle deshun Watson
their starting quarterback true and uh
Nick chub went out a few games ago oh
yeah I saw that point brought up and
then a lot of people brought up the
counter point I I brought up and I was
like yeah that that makes tons of
yeah son of a
[__] I've had enough of these Cowboy
safeties I'm just I'm over it who uh
filled in for um
Diggs the cornerback for you guys oh
donon Bland he's good is he good the
slot Corner that replace donon bland is
Jordan Lewis and he's not great but uh
also give us a hint for the next FL
guest I've told you guys it's Michael
blin and Trevor Wallace Get Hype we fire
dring tomorrow for the next flagrant
guest oh I was just with Trevor this
weekend oh word Kansas City oh that's
right he in Kansas City yeah he flew in
y'all might have taking the same ass
flight honestly sweet kid he's the best
man he's
great we went to uh Kansas City Joe's
Barbecue with him Joe's Barbecue is
great I I like um what's the one I like
with the ribs uh gates gates no not
Gates um we had it last time you were
there which one was it for Jack Stack
fire yeah also too I don't know if we
have any Kansas City fans watching this
thing I'm going to be honest with you
guys this hurts me to say this awesome
barbecue better than Kansas City
Barbecue wow brisket I'm going out there
and saying it right now uh um burnin for
sure better that's beef right pork yes
see the beef is better I don't I don't
eat beef though so I like Kansas City oh
Fair yeah cuz it's a lot more brisket is
a Texas brisket is the Texas thing and I
can't brisket and oh my my Lord come on
dude that catch another
flag this I think this one might be
holding I'm telling you it's a sloppy
game
man wow yeah a lot of
flags someone said look at akos holding
his dinner get your racist jokes right
dude thank you he thank you for
correcting this
man this is Happy dude look at this guy
chilling Asian somebody's
said yeah that's a whole Demarcus
Lawrence has been good somebody said the
cross-legged uh pose tucking in your man
[__] which one cuz I just noticed both
of that's hilarious our [__] gay no
this guy pointed out that I'm in a rap
video with my friend F who's a rapper Dy
rapper and I'm sitting in a Rolls-Royce
this exact same way and it's very funny
oh wow what the [__] dude are you
kidding
crazy you saw this weekend though right
yeah F yeah I went to the show fire so
good so good where was it at it looked
like a great venue the sultan room in
Brooklyn that's what it called it was a
great
venue he rocked it out yeah he rocked it
out dude crowd control was great I never
seen him live and I was like oh this
guy's great dude great live performer
there's been 16 Flags this game really I
mean yeah that was crazy there was
second and 24 and then 23 yard pass on
second and
that's hilarious Yo the person who just
said honestly Nashville could beat
Austin get out of here that's crazy
that's insane Nashville so crazy I
honestly and I respect you but [__] you
I mean that's a very average barbecue
you know what slaps in Nashville though
princes Fried Chicken yes
yes yes the fried chicken is fire they I
think that's princess is like the place
that made uh hot fried chicken or
whatever what's it called oh the hot
chicken hot chicken is you know
apparently the rumor is that the guy
Prince that invented it he was cheating
on his wife and she got fed up with him
so she made his chicken like super super
spicy and tried to [__] with him and
then he loved it and that's the when
they start wow that's the R I don't know
if that's a real thing or not oh my
goodness oh I thought he was going to
catch that
yeah oh if he caught that that's
six Kevin Patel is asking if you served
in the military yes he did yes na right
uh Air Force Air Force yeah I didn't
really serve though so please don't give
me like that too much credit what you
talking about you were in Iraq right
where I've I yeah I just did four months
though it wasn't like you saw some [__]
though right yeah I mean yeah anytime
you go into I mean you're doing comedy
to cope with your PTSD you did something
probably I mean that's yeah edly as the
mafia members say
allegedly oh wow that's a flag for sure
we're not going to you're not going to
call that
a that a flag that's there's no way
that's not a
flag that's crazy if they don't call
that he pushed him into
him yeah I
say is it like the movie Full Metal
Jacket someone want say have you seen
Full Metal Jacket
yeah um he's a joker you guys don't
realize that
yet uh yeah no no it's not full metal
jacket there are some crazy people
though military is like the most diverse
working force apparently so they
say but it's uh you definitely meet some
weird
kids yeah there was definitely some kids
where I I when I met them I was like you
may or may not have signed up to kill
people and I feel that for me I feel
that energy
from I was just like you know what uh
I'm glad we're friends yeah why did you
why did you sign up not to kill people
no no yeah believe or not yeah no I no I
I knew ahead of time that I was going on
the boxing team
oh yeah i' already known Peter I is that
Peter I slip dog is that my best friend
from middle school let me
know if it's Pete dude I love you I miss
you when are you going to
Orlando I don't know I did Orlando in
September of like 21 but I'll do it on
the next I got to get another hour
together guys I film the special I got
to get the next hour up and then it's
going to happen how do you feel about
Orlando uh I mean who cannot like Disney
World I am doing Utah I'm doing Utah in
January I'm going to be at Wise Guys
Comedy Club in Salt Lake City so OG Gary
buy your [__] tickets uh I've heard
it's fantastic it makes sense cuz you
can't probably joke the cities where you
aren't really allowed to have a sense of
humor the clubs are great Portland great
Club San Francisco yeah great Club
because you can't make jokes cuz they're
they're cuck cities Y and then Utah is
religious cuck City same with uh San
Francisco too I would imagine great
great City yeah San Francisco well I did
a show at I comedy great I did a show at
cobs great comedy because the people who
are coming to my show or our like
they're like I know what kind of Comedy
this is and I know I don't [__] with
what's happening in San Francisco this
is going to be fun this is a break from
that makes
sense look already getting cute dog yep
hey thank you dude you're not wrong kou
Peter I miss you dude that's my best
friend since I was probably 14 years old
I don't ever get to see these guys
anymore you should take a trip dude you
me Gerald Gerald's not on this live
stream because he's not as good of a
friend as you Peter just goes
buddy that's it buddy that's all we need
figure it out
we took a trip I had them come to Denver
and they had never really seen me
perform and it was at Comedy Works which
is like the best club in America and it
was so fun and it was the first time we
had traveled together since probably
ever I yeah I don't think we'd ever
taken a trip together the three of us
are
you oh no this is a fumble huh
no
regular regular
episode yeah this is a fumble and it's
going to be Chargers ball I thought that
they recovered it I thought uh no
Chargers recovered
it he pushing to him though that's what
I would have
thought damn that's crazy field position
too I don't really like Brandon Staley
either I actually think he's not the
best Co he should got fired last year
but the problem is who's the good coach
left Mike m Daniels is great yeah your
guy Reed is great Mike Shanahan maybe
the best in the league who else belich
he's not a lot man sure honestly even
belich it's looking like did Tom Brady
just carry you for like [__] 18 years
buddy I CU I'd still take him but yeah
maybe no I'm just I'm I'm just wondering
out loud because it's like I mean
literally you know he goes to another
team they they were what 500 last year
no yeah they haven't been I don't think
they've had hav been relevant but think
I'm just thinking about even before he
was in with the Patriots he was with the
and they weren't [__] so it's like who
was who really helped who I've love that
too cuz that was their whole falling out
is Brady was like I can I just have some
say on how this team run at all M I just
want to feel wanted and belich was like
no this is all me and he's dying without
him and it's so fun to see it really is
I love that I love that but also like
Tom Brady getting pushed around by his
wife his coach guy's just trying to put
his foot now have some sort of any I
mean he's just trying to have some sort
of respect can anyone respect me at all
yo I heard he's dating enena what's her
name I don't know how you pronounce her
name no Bradley Cooper's ex-wife really
yeah I've heard that's what he's she's a
joint dude she joint yeah I don't know
if I've ever seen
her I mean you're Tom Brady though also
too Jazelle moved on to like
a a Brazilian jiu-jitsu black belt it's
like that was the move yeah that's
supposed to impress me that's not even a
lateral move yeah oh he can fight Tom
Brady can fight too probably right fight
you in courts yeah also he's 6'5 he can
probably throw
mhm I'm called him bottom G who Tom
Brady bottom G that's
funny Arena Arena has a hell of a roster
I imagine can you type the name let us
know who's she been with Bradley Cooper
Kanye Tom Brady that's PR c kany yeah
wow a lot of
these Dallas just lost that fumble yeah
I think you're right
buddy I want to be annoyed my point is
though is that he got still got pushed
into him and that there was no flag for
that
age oh the Cowboys challenged that it
was a fumble uh it was called a fumble
Cowboys challenge
wow also this Irena girl I don't know oh
she's Ronaldo that's
a that's an awful throw are you kidding
me there's that was not remotely
catchable seems like there's seems like
there's a lot of fall in Gilmore Too Am
I Wrong yeah there is but this wasn't
remotely
catchable Charles Barkley what a piece
of Tom what's going on what's happening
what's Chuck doing yeah what do that
even he wants to fight him or he wants
to [__] him yeah that's
crazy I guess that
was what did you guys give up to get
Gilmore from from New England that's
nothing yeah but we would hope he'd be
good especially when you lose Diggs yeah
if we lost Gilmore with with Diggs and
Bland we'd be fine
but but Gilmore has been
crap Irena a lot of these girls just
have real ra they're just as impressive
rosters as some of these men
have Derek terer got the roster of
rosters that's true I would that was one
thing when I saw his documentary I was
like
wow oh he's Captain my Captain yeah
ultimate winner dude that's
crazy who is this gentleman I just
checked back in and sir you look like
Nick Diaz if he didn't have CTE well
crazy story about the Diaz
actually I one think about that we're
not friends I'll tell you that
much they are a type and you don't know
if I have CT that's also still on the on
the
Block if you got CTE is super Latin
hot versus Usman Usman I actually think
Usman really yeah I think the experience
is going to get him oh dude Matt McCoy
almost fought Stipe when we were in
Cleveland Matt McCoy asked me to DM him
to fight him yeah and Stipe got back to
me but he got back to me oh that's a
it's Fourth and fourth and one that's
big great tackle Maris Bell's been
playing great thank God he answered late
I mean that was one of those ones where
I go I said it in the moment and then I
was and then when we were looking it up
and we're like oh he's training for a
fight I was like he's not training for a
fight he's training for the fight the
fight yeah I remember just thinking
being like oh this going to be bad yeah
C responded he was the sweetest and he
was down but he got back to us we were
on our way look at this little Asian
just gas dude you know I'm you know I
love Asians right yeah yeah I remember
that yeah I remember you telling me that
yeah which I would you're so you're so
Midwest I think it might be the it might
be the military oh yeah there you go
went
abroad I get closer on the couch to be
honest with you look how I'm old this
dog you think I'm heteros close on the
couch is actually too much space if he
to me yeah I'm not into it yeah um wait
he had busy hands in a positive attitude
God what were we saying oh yeah Stipe
yeah he was so sweet and he could have
thought is Jon Jones The Greatest UFC
fighter ever in my opinion
yes
never gone up against and even the
people that he didn't dominate maybe
originally he he ran it back and and got
him I mean like the uh V or not vcan um
Alexander guson M when they ran that
back I mean he just he let it be no
doubt that he was the better
[Music]
man oh wow F that's a good that's a
great play see that's a great play call
that's something the Cowboys wouldn't
have done
cowboy who is this lady who yeah who the
[__] is this anime [__] yeah who's this
anim that's right at my alley that I'm
going hard eyes
bazooka yeah that's uh this seems like
one of those games that all of a sudden
was kind of boring for three quarters
and then the fourth quarter is going
toit it's kind of like the Giants in the
uh bills last night it was like 76 after
three quarters like this game sucks and
then it became good at the after the
fourth what about
khabib khabib's the khabib's great I'll
say this somebody brought this up
recently and they were like dude had
only like four or five title defenses or
something and I was like wow you're
right it wasn't really that much we give
it quick to give that guy the goat
status and I'm not saying he wasn't I
it's all this is beat everyone so
but he beat he beat everyone so
decisively I mean it was just there
wasn't really any question it was so
intense watching and it was always the
number one Contender you know it was
always the guy the only guy at the time
that I think they could say he didn't
fight was Tony Ferguson but that was
just because of in injuries otherwise he
beat everybody that was at the top in
indecisively too [__] treated Justin
gatei like a
child po like a
child once but that was like it yeah
honestly the best the guy who had the
best fight against him was Ally quenta
was the east coast boy he did five
rounds and it was somewhat close oh he
did he went through distance though
wow did you predict the Dylan
DQ uh I actually predicted at first
after he came on flagrant he was so
confident and he like truly believed he
was going to win and I was like I think
he got it dude no and then I was like oh
or he will lose and then get
disqualified to try to save face but he
still didn't save face because he didn't
throw any punches it was embarass no
punches yeah it was an
awass it was
awful I could Andrew and Mark were at
the at the match were they they were
performing in Manchester right match
really yeah I would have my way I would
have my way with Dylan DAV I've never
been less jealous of anyone you think
you would destroy D I think I could get
off this couch right now not training
I'd have my way he's strong
I I was shocked at how strong he was
yeah he just sucks at boxing though oh
boing stand boxing no sorry that's what
I meant yeah I thought you me MMA no MMA
I don't I think he got boxing yeah I
would definitely have my way with him
yeah I believe that yeah but MMA no he's
very good at uh on the ground he's an
animal but stup is just so so bad I mean
he missed both takedowns in that fight
true although Logan is actually was a
wrestler yeah Logan is an athlete dude
no he's an athlete collegiate right yeah
no he was really he was in high school
he was he went to State tried to get him
in the headlock did he really all state
wrestler yeah yeah no he was an all
state wrestler for sure I I don't know
if he got offers to go who is she look
at that mouth this is Vegeta's wife dude
you don't know who this is no I don't
Piccolo's sister dude drag Ball Z how do
you
get her arms are bent the opposite way
yeah how' you do that yeah that's
crazy do you think you pull this
out make a statement right now 7-Eleven
left in the game IAC the Cowboys win
it say felt racist uh I think the
Cowboys win this game you do I don't
know I mean I don't know I'm just
talking but I think the Cowboys win this
game what's up IG if you want to watch a
better version of this is on YouTube you
want an actual straight on shot
youtube.com
complaining yeah you know what I mean
people always complain sweatshirt mad
ill-fitting whatever shouts to Ruby
Ros the Izzy comment that's a good
question does Izzy come back I don't
know man damn
it I don't know I've always said this
we've talked about this before I I love
Izzy man yeah is my one of my favorite
fighters in entertainers period but
getting behind the mic great I think I
think you get to a point where you make
so much money though that it's like this
the old quote about uh who said I can't
remember if it was Joe Lewis or what
it's like it's hard to get out of the
bed at 400 in the morning and when
you're when you're sleeping in satin
sheets I've heard you say that it's
tough man when youve made a certain
amount of money and you're living well
it's just like what are we doing
here that was a duck dude if that passes
on the money Gallup would have got at
least two more yards that's Michael
Gallup we're talking about you're right
the white helmets are ugly as [__] yeah
I don't like the white helmet I'm not
into it what do you feel about Cooper
Rush Cooper Rush he's a great backup I
don't think he could be a starter at all
but he's a great backup but you have
faith in him if Dak is if Dak goes down
he can hold he can hold things down I
mean he's not going to beat a good team
yeah but I I'm only asking CU I was
watching Tyrod Taylor last night I was
like he's a good backup yeah a good
backup is great who's y'all's backup
again the guy from Michigan uh Chad
Henny or something yeah Chad H yeah oh
no this is not looking good that's bad
for business as I said the cowboy always
won you know what I thought about their
last touchdown was on kind of like a not
a fluke play but like kind of a random
60- yard pass and the charters have been
driving up and down non-stop yeah
so see how do the Dallas Cowboys you
have a great defense you have zero sacks
tonight I don't think they're a great
defense I think the Cowboys always sell
us a bill of goods and then I I buy I
usually don't buy it this year I bought
it because I thought the Gilmore pickup
was great I thought the Brandon Cooks
pickup was great I thought
M Mike mcarthy be good with play calling
and all that and I just I don't know
we're an idiot we're we're all
idiots there you go all right make
something there it is holding that's
great third and 19 you're going to
[Music]
scramble look at the flag
though let's see maybe it's an illegal
contact
there's wild comments in this the hoodie
makes it look like camouflage where os's
hand is coming out of his dick that's
hilarious I don't even know what that
means but for some reason that's funny
to me I'm holding happy underneath like
that okay let's go buddy do people like
her or Tua that's my that's a good
question now because he
has yeah but it's that's my thing though
too I remember like that's when I knew
um that's when I really appreciated
Mahomes last year
when we didn't have Tyreek and he was
still putting up numbers and still
winning Super Bowl I was like oh he's
that guy I picked yall to win the Super
Bowl at the beginning of the year when
everybody was picking Buffalo I said I
think Kansas City yeah cuz I don't think
you need one if you have a few if you
have a great tight end especially I
don't think you necessarily need like a
bunch of options at wi
receiv if you invest in the defense and
whatever like look at Tom Brady when
he's with the Patriots who's his best
receiver one1 TR Brown yes yeah I mean
out that he had Randy Moss but yeah and
they didn't win that year oh you're
right oh look at this oh
wow great play call that holding penalty
we were just talking [__] about not no
play call yeah that was
nice I think this about two everybody
was down on him last year and hated him
wantan to get rid of him and then to it
yeah well he also had those concussions
he had a lot of that too he said he took
Jiu-Jitsu to learn how to fall I thought
it was Judah that taught you how to fall
yeah but he said he took Jiu-Jitsu to
learn how to fall and hope he hasn't got
a concussion knock on wood oh my God a
bad throw I mean a bad throw across your
body so Parsons hasn't gotten any
pressure on the quarterback he's gotten
a pressure he's drawing a hold
but yeah it hasn't been what we thought
it would would be it's
interesting I love Michael Parsons
fellow foot fetishist he loves a good
foot yeah he loves a good foot dude
really you like you like feet love feet
really yeah so one of the reasons I
married my wife was one of the reasons I
married my wife that's my wife I won't
speak about our sex lives but you know I
apologize it's all good dude I
understand you asking cuz you know who
else was a virgin until he got married
or whatever but uh I was looking toes
today too so I was on my Tarantino [__]
I was joking around what you got to do
messing around we just good foot is a
good foot but my wife had descending toe
length which Indian girls don't normally
have so I was like I got to pass this
girl out had the waterfall the waterfall
toes yeah staircase yeah yeah yeah big
deal nice Michael Parson randomly during
Super Bowl week he's doing an interview
last year and they said what's one thing
most people don't know about you in y go
um I have a foot fetish and then the
announcers are dead silent and it's so
funny let's go wow CD lamb
boy you know I love about the announcers
a lot of times is how like gay they'll
get sometimes yeah like look at the way
he sucks that ball in before he gets
every you're like all right so downam
buddy
that's that's so funny yo I hate these
comments that are like trade deak and go
get shadur Sanders trade deak and go get
Caleb Williams like who's who's on the
other side agreeing to this trait yeah
also to like
who's the you never know how these guys
are going to turn out yeah that's also
true what's up big guy oh this is
adorable dude yeah keev happy don't ever
love you like this bro Is This
Love
feel is
this WOW HS me
that is
this someone said toes before bros
that's I'm going to get that on a shirt
that's a
bar that's great great you want a soda
or something no I'm good buddy thank you
you don't have
alcohol I also don't want to indulge
your clear drinking problem yeah thank
you I appreciate
that already had to steer away from that
tonight catch he caught it I think he
caught that I'd be
surprised whose dog is this so cautious
it's my dog cheating on me with dog but
yeah may be my
dog I mean you guys are really wasting
some time here too yeah which is
good o no he got his arm underneath that
oh he oh
no did it pop out the side
yeah
is that worth challenging for six yards
I mean I guess you're fairly certain
it's going to get you're going to win
but didn't the the uh the Chargers just
traded Jackson Jr to somebody didn't
they who the Chargers traded who their
best quarterback to somebody recently I
saw that earlier this year why would
they do that yeah [__] somebody they
traded from New England they got rid of
quickly right yeah yeah something Jack
Jun yeah yeah yeah yeah I forget his
name I don't know why they did that that
was like their best I'm so glad you
watch football dude this is such I'm so
happy I just assumed you didn't I don't
know why no buddy I'm locked
in God a it from Kansas City yeah you
know
you no I I had to I ended up do fler
late so yeah it was the danis episode
that was like three and a half four
hours
yeah said was
yeah I felt that Jason Jackson
[Music]
yeah Miami is somebody said sorry I just
saw this one because it was earlier in
the thing but somebody said Miami is a
worst fans I agree I mean talk about a
city that just
there's really no built-in fan base it's
a bunch of
transplants they just they don't ever
really get behind their teams unless
they're good yeah uh yeah I've never
been I any city that has a great NTI it
probably doesn't have good fans yeah
yeah facts Atlanta doesn't have great
fans La has terrible fans Miami has
terrible fans Vegas might have good fans
but also I feel like Vegas night life is
different I think if you're a Vegas
resident you're like not into that no
they don't go out at all my cousins used
to they never went out cuz yeah I feel
like the whole city is just like so
gross with it yeah let's go wow that's a
big boy play right there that's a third
nine brand might have over 30 yards that
might have cost me my prize pick right
there well well Austin Eckler didn't run
for [__]
anyway
great athletic is [__]
too Cowboys are got terrible protection
today or Dak is got terrible protection
today
everybody always Raves about your
offensive line though it's that's like
six years old I'm not saying you're I'm
saying they're still holding on to that
yeah yeah yeah somebody a couple people
been pointing it out recently when they
lost Travis Fredericks their Center who
was like incredible he retired early uh
what the [__] ref what an the absolute
[__] but once he retired the line wasn't
ever the
[Music]
same
ref got pushed around yeah ref's getting
Abus in this
[Music]
game he's trying to be a trying to be a
thug about it like yell at people
they're just throwing them
[Music]
around yeah the Chargers fans do act
like they care but in La no one cares I
remember when I watched
I think it was a Chargers and uh Raiders
earlier this year and half of the
stadium when they pan to it was like
more than half was like black and and
and silver I was like G yeah they're
terrible nothing worse than watching
like somebody's home game and it being
the opposing team's colors you're like
God you can't even they care about the
Lakers yeah that's it for whatever
reason but yet again but that always
goes back to their fair weather fans
they're just they only care if you're
good yeah it's true if the Lakers were
bad for 10 years they wouldn't care
yeah oh it was remember uh back when
they were um before they uh when LeBron
first got there oh I see all the years
before that they
were they just didn't
care I'm
so was that porn kev's watching porn I
thought my airpod picked up right
what kind of video
yeah well that's a lovely
video Yeah somebody said mention the
Rams yeah we're particularly pissed
about that in
Missouri the so they're owned by they
were St Louis yes they were in St Louis
they're owned by the Kies who own
Walmart and this don't on Walmart
anymore no no it's split up amongst like
10 different people or something like
that and
um uh the Kies are one are part of that
and he owns the the Rams and this guy
had like beef with the city
of yeah that's weird it's weird that you
don't just throw it to him he should
also be the f I feel like the first
person that you're looking at
yeah 11
15 Dak for Zack Wilson's abely yeah
that's I mean Dak is not that bad guys I
think you get a first for him at least
Carson Wentz got a first the [__] are we
talking about I think Carson got a
second but but it was a he play enough
games that's
oh
oh you know who doesn't make that play
Ezekiel Elliott so who
cares still the better option
[__] that's a hard catch though that's
uncatchable that's tough he had him
that's n he missed him yeah he overthrew
him damn settle him for the field goal
see if this comes back to B him in the I
know an he's got to make it 39 yards
good good that he made that look easy
yeah I mean it's 39 I just I don't
know when did they back the uh extra
point up to it's at the 35 now it's yeah
35 yards
now and the year before when it was like
a 19 yard extra point kickers were
making crazy field goals and then they
started missing a bunch of extra points
and field goals and one kicker was
saying when it was extra points were
like automatic it was an easy way to get
in Rhythm it was like shooting free
throws so we would make all kinds of
field goals and once you pulled that
back we can't even get in Rhythm the
whole game so it really does make it
more
exciting yeah the uh notice a lot of
people missing a lot of these extra
points Lance are you guys you think
you'll trade
him I hope they can at least trade
him I just don't see a world in which
they keep him or what's the point of
keeping him oh yeah Peter my boy lived
in La he said there's no Charters fans
out there he was in he was right by the
stadium too yeah and he was like there's
and even now if you listen for the
Cowboys Roars it's
loud of course but see that's another
thing too the
Cowboys uh they have fans everywhere me
yeah that's I understand why people hate
Cowboys fans is because the fans in
other cities are so obnoxious the Cowboy
fans that live here every year they're
like we're going to win the Super Bowl
blah blah blah in Dallas we're as far as
I know we're not like that yeah we all
hate Jerry Jones we all hate rooting for
the team we miserably watch it yeah like
abuse victim so you're not you're not
you're not you're not like the Jets fans
no no every year there's hope and then
six games no we'll buy in but then we
get so mad at ourselves for buying in
yeah which is what I did this
year
uhoh yeah only Cowboys and Raiders fans
in La they love the Raiders yeah no no
ra because the Raiders have always been
in constant they've always but they're
in they went to LA then Oakland then Las
Vegas La Cowboys are just everywhere
like the second most popular team in
every city is the Cowboys Philadelphia
it's the Steelers Steelers are always
mad popular
Cowboys Patriots fans now and 49ers I
feel like yeah all those fans travel
well for some
reason just everywhere for whatever
reason a lot of we'll if they up but on
that
last
bottom we're also talking about teams
who have like multiple multiple multiple
it's easy to be a fan when you're
winning all the time all four of those
teams have like the Cowboys do not dude
I grew up I was the first year I watched
football the Cowboys were seven and nine
then 11 and five then Super Bowl Super
Bowl championship Super Bowl so I was
like oh this is just what I didn't know
that it fell off I was like they're good
now so they're just going to be good
forever yeah and if I I wish they won
those Super Bowls now I would have
appreciated them so much I would have
cried but back then I was just like oh
this is that why you have a soft spot
for the bills too cuz you guys just
rough shot over them for so many years I
was rooting for them in the suit both
Super Bowl before because they lost to
NFC East times east teams every time
they lost to the Giants who I didn't
like they lost to the Redskins who I
really didn't like yeah cuz that used to
be the big rivalry and then they lost to
the Cowboys and I felt bad for them and
they lost to Cowboys again those seem
were solid
yeah Olivia Rodrigo is this generation
is Taylor Swift I think is she is that
her yeah I don't even know who that is
it's how old I'm out she's Taylor Swift
for kids now it's
fair Cowboys going to Cowboys so old not
knowing that yeah somebody said Cowboy
going to Cowboys I say that about the
Clippers and I think the Cowboys are
very similar to the Clippers yeah yeah
oh you're back buddy good to see you wow
I didn't pay enough attention is that
what it is good to see you yo IG this is
like the Cowboy season you just you're
in you're out you're back in oh yeah
nice IG if you want to finish the game
with us on YouTube live we're watching
we're pulling up videos oh yeah what's
your favorite viral video I pulled up
two earlier that I love Daddy chill did
you ever see that one did I show you
that one no what the hell is even that
we we'll watch that you know you know
which one I love and this is going to
date me yet again as how old I am do you
remember the guy who used to go oh
chicken
[__] remember in the woods the woods
yeah the black kid yes [__]
unforgivable that's what it was called
yeah okay we're watching this again it's
probably mad different people in the
chat anyway oh
yeah your trck on my property
outtt let me have this house JT let you
have my house my [__] we was your trust
on my property you didn't wish my yard
all of you Daddy
chill what the hell is
[Laughter]
even it's so good dude it's the best oh
that landed like a punch line it's so
good what the hell is even that what the
hell is even that is that is so good
that's
great that's such a that's such a great
question there's so
many videos that I
love I'm trying to think of like one
that separates
itself I was reading chat that was some
[__] there you go oo there it is mik
right there I was just asking about him
earlier I better a line
up back to Third and
10 Daddy what
the that's
great do they not have timeout I can't
where's the timeouts at no time out left
no timeouts
wow they used him before the two-minute
warning god let's go that'sall game
let's [__] go that's it is that
Gilmore Gilmore got that we were just
talking [__] on him
earlier
[Applause]
wow I don't think so know it's tough I
don't think so we're going to review it
but I think that's a pick that was a bad
throw by her this is so funny this girl
is hilarious is this why they
funny just
teasing
damn right in his
chest
no that's it that's great there you go
great play is tore up huh yeah what's
going on with his knee let's figure that
out that's blood for
[Music]
sure now you kneel it out there's it's
over Herbert Herbert yeah it's
[Music]
over you see that University of Miami
coach run the ball with 30 seconds left
for no reason instead of kneeling and
then they fumbled and then the other
team scored a touchdown and won the game
no really I forget his name he used to
coach Peter would know he used to coach
Michigan State look at that Cowboys
win
wow didn't look great but you take it
hey Tosh turn your TV on guy do
both we can't we can't watch the game
otherwise we get flagged also you're too
poor to afford to watch the game and
that's not our problem so I don't know
how to tell you
hey IG live those of you who watch thank
you appreciate you YouTube live thank
youall those you who watch appreciate
you shouts to prize Pi priz picks.com
promo code aash PR thanks to Matt McCoy
for coming through I'm going have him
back I'm so happy this guy because he
comes on the road with me now a lot so
if you're on the road with me it's a
solid chance we'll see Matt McCoy's
going to be in Atlanta and uh anything
you'd like to plug not at all man come
see him come see him in Atlanta getting
funnier know this guy just started
comedy no I got you this guy just
started comedy what 3 years ago four
years ago four years ago young he's baby
he's not trying to put any Clips out yet
but he's getting so good so quickly and
come see him feature for me I got com
comments about you in Stress Factory
multiple people being like yo who's your
opener you're so funny really let's go
yeah appreciate that so Instagram love
y'all thank you everybody who watched
I'm going to sign off of that YouTube
live appreciate you thank you we did it
guys Cowboys 4 and two Cowboys we're
back Super
Bowl Matt what's your IG mark it down
right now it's uh Real mattor McCoy real
Matt uncore McCoy there's another real
Matt regular McCoy with no underscore I
don't even know yeah I think so yeah cuz
I had they forced me they had my hand
all right beautiful kind of like Jerry
Jones had Jason Garrett's
hand
boom Cowboys with the dub huh can you
believe it let's go are we still on
YouTube uh